All right, we're good to go. I think
we'll go ahead and get started right on 4 o'clock. So we'll start the work
session. And the first item to talk about today is a discussion
about the towns at Briley Farms Phase B, an update. And I
believe Steven's got this, right?
With Greg?
Hopefully. Or we can just invite Greg
up if you're— OK. Go ahead and tell
us what you got. Let me plug in my— so you can see
what I'm talking about here. Yep.
Good deal. So first I wanted to say thank you.
Last week at the City Council meeting, you approved the first
amendment to the development agreement, and that allowed us to count the
4 that were in lots from— or the
4 lots that were in Plat 2 that we hadn't anticipated when we made the
development agreement. Agree to the sequencing with parks
and platform. So I appreciate that.
I used to be on a planning commission, and one of my pet peeves
was when people would come in and we'd give them recommendations
or make suggestions, and it seemed like they would kind of do
some token changes but didn't really listen to us. And when they came back,
it was like, "Were you not taking notes?" Yeah.
So we tried to take good notes from last time,
and. Make some modifications with Element
Homes as architectural partners, and we wanted to come and kind
of run this by you and get your, your feedback.
So last time when we were here, the mayor asked about the possibility
of pushing the townhome back and extending the
garage out 2 feet, and we actually
did it about 3 feet. And so this new design
is 24 feet deep on the garage.
And we had the— our architectural partners put in some
different trucks and minivans and sedans because
I remember you asked about different cars and how
they would fit. So this is a Ford F-150
crew cab and it's parked in the
garage. You can see that they put in garbage cans to scale. Yeah. And then
they have some minivans. There's a Honda Odyssey and a Toyota
Sienna and some different sedans like a Honda Accord
and a Honda Civic and a Toyota Camry and a Tesla Y.
But from our conversation last time,
you said you wanted a garage that was useful and
functional instead of being so tight that you couldn't have
both cars and garbage cans in it. And I remember one
of the questions was a concern about the stairs,
if the stairs extended too far into the garage or if there was a landing
that would reduce the usable area of the
garage. And we double-checked the grades and everything,
and all of the garages will be able to have a one-step
maximum. So it's just one step that's inside the garage
and it doesn't affect the usable space.
And the,
the reason why we were doing this, if you'll recall, we had
in our development agreement that there would be 40 townhomes
built that were 3 stories that had a minimum of a 600-square-foot garage.
And we've built 20 of those so far, and they just haven't
been as well received by the market. And so looking
forward at the, the last lots that we have to
build with the larger garage design. We felt like if we were
able to do a 2-story instead of a 3, and with this
updated design that's 24 feet deep,
we wanted to get your input on that to
see what your thoughts were. But we think this could, you know, still offer a
design with a bigger garage area that's
functional, but also would be helpful
to have that interest from the market.
So I'm happy to answer any questions or
hear your thoughts on it. So would these be in lieu of the 3-car
or the 4-car garages, or would you be doing these 2-car— this
new 2-car garage design also on the other units that were already planned as 2-car
garages? So the way the development agreement
was is that there were to be 40 with the larger garage and all
the rest of them would be the standard 2-car design.
And any that we would change would
need to have a plat amendment to the plat, and we want to keep going
forward with the construction of the other ones. So the 20
that have been built are these 4 in Plat 2. These 16
in Plat 3, and then the ones that are left to
build are these 4 fourplexes and 1 fiveplex.
And so what we would propose is we would actually end up
with 41 of the larger garage design instead of 40,
but it would— the 20 that are already done
would count towards the requirement, but we would do it and propose
to do an amendment to the development agreement
to allow 21 of these larger garages to
replace the 20, the 3-story ones, with this
minimum 600-square-foot garage.
So if I'm not mistaken, you're asking if this is palatable so
you could come back and ask for another amendment, right?
That's how we would memorialize the agreement, would be a second
amendment to the development agreement. Does it— is there any feedback?
Any— does this seem to meet the requirement
that we were looking for?
And I, I didn't mention the garage area with this extended
garage is 496 square feet. So, so maybe
to help the council— What's that? What was
the prior square footage of the garage? The prior square
footage was, um, I believe 421.
421. Yeah, of the 2 stories. Yeah. And this
is 496, so. And it's 24 feet
deep. But, but to be clear, I mean, I want to make sure we're understanding
the ask correctly. You're required to build 600 square foot garages
now on those 3 stories, right? Yes, that's correct. And so you're asking to build
a 496 square foot garage in lieu of those 600 square
foot garages because— and then keep it a 2 story. Because it's a little easier
to market. I mean, is that a fair— is that a fair assessment?
When I say the market, it's not like the marketing, like the advertising.
Like we've, we've taken them to market and the— You're just having a hard
time selling them and you want them to sell. And so do we. The buyers
have been tended to gravitate
towards the 2-story more than the 3-story.
So the changes that would come back are 100 square foot less garage,
and these would remain 3-story or 2-story? So these would be a 2-story.
So it's just the 2 changes from 3-story to 2-story
and the garage from 600 to 500. Yeah. Ford. Well,
and so I'm going to ask a question. I mean, let me say this.
Thank you for listening to at least what our concerns were. It's obvious that
you, that you understood the intent of at least what my concerns are, and I
think probably what the council's are in general. You're welcome, and thanks for letting
us know what the current concerns were. But with that said,
I get— I guess for me the question would be, would be simply this: is
there a way to incorporate this into more units that have that
smaller footprint or that smaller garage? I don't know if there is or not.
I mean, that's why I'm asking, because if we're, if we're
willing to consider this, and perhaps we should,
I'm not saying that, that I'm a yes or no
on it, but perhaps we should. But if we're going to do it, I'd like
to know, can we incorporate something beneficial like this into the design of some of
the remaining 2-story units? That's what I'm interested in hearing about.
So, um,
the, the intent, um, had been
to do the, uh, the Platt
Amendment, and that was one One other thing that I guess is
kind of more of a procedural thing on these 4 units.
We did a lot line adjustment, which the state law allows
and is a little faster and easier for us, but our feedback from the staff
was that it's not as easy for them, and so they asked if we would
have our surveyor do a plat amendment rather than a lot line adjustment,
and we're happy to do that to make it easier and better for the staff.
But to answer your question, to get up to the,
the 40, it would actually be 41. We were intending
to do the larger garage on the, the 21 units that
are currently shown with the red 3 for the 3 stories,
and that would kind of get above the 40 with
the larger garage. That was the, the intent of
the original development agreement. Can I restate the question?
I think what Councilmember Wright's asking is that these units up here,
what is the size of the garage on those, and would you increase it
in exchange for decreasing these, make those a little bit more
palatable as well? So the other units would also, you know,
in exchange for making these different, is that right?
That really is the intent of my question, is there a way to
perhaps increase the size of those that aren't required to have the larger size In
exchange for reducing those that are required to be 600 feet to the 496?
That's really the question. I don't know if so architecturally
that's something that can happen, right? So from
an architectural standpoint, we wanted to get feedback before we
had the structural engineers go through and redesign the structure. And this,
this one's already been poured, the footing and foundation walls. It's getting backfilled
right now, and this one is getting dug
and poured in the next week or so. Which ones could
you make an adjustment to if you're able to do so? So I would have
to get with Element Homes on their,
their schedule, but it— in
addition to doing the, the re-engineering of the structural
engineering, we also have to do the plat amendment before we could do it.
So our thought had been to do these 5 Last,
so there would be time for the plat amendment to happen. But this
one we were hesitant to because we've already installed the trail. But if we had
to tear out the trail and redo it, we could. These two,
it would really depend on the timing of the plat amendment. So I,
I don't want to dodge the question, but I don't have enough information to answer.
But we, we could get with Element Homes and see what their schedule is.
Get with kind of the planning department and see how long they think the—
and our surveyor— and see how long they think the plat amendment could take.
So I've kind of hogged the time, and I'm going to just leave this.
I'll give you the, my last little bit, and then, and then step back and,
and let the other council members give you some thoughts. I'd be willing
to entertain what you're asking if there is some additional
benefit in creating better off-street parking for these
residents that are over and above those 40 that you're already obligated to do
that on. If all you're going to do is change a 600-square-foot garage
for a 500-square-foot and go from a 3-story to 2-story, I don't care. To me,
that's not, that's not a huge upside.
I mean, it's actually a downside from my perspective in that we're losing,
we're reducing space in those garages. But if you were able to
say, look, we want to do these 496-square-foot garages and
we're willing to incorporate some better garage design to To
incorporate the feedback that we heard council give to ensure that the
people who either purchase these or rent them will have access
to a useful garage. That's that's really what we're talking about,
and they'll be able to store their their their their garbage cans
inside and get two vehicles. I like the vehicles that you used.
I think those are very appropriate. I think
that that many of our residents. Are going to have 2
vehicles in a similar setup. And it makes sense. It gets them inside.
It gives them some protection. And it also keeps them off the street.
So for me, at least, I'd be willing to entertain that if—
I'd be willing to entertain going from the 600
to 496, let you go from 3-story to 2-story if there's
some additional benefit in those units that aren't required to have the larger
That's really what I'm looking for, is, is there a chance to do that?
Okay. Mayor, can you go back to
the one that shows like the overall— I think it
really comes down to parking,
and I'm grateful that one, you're listening to the market,
and two, that you've made an attempt to change, because certainly we've
had developers come in here 3, 4 times And every
single time it's the same stupid thing. And it's like, you guys didn't listen to
us last time, but you like listened. So I appreciate the effort to make a
change. I guess one of the suggestions that I would give, and I'm going
to kind of look to my fellow council members to see if this would be
enough, what if they added some additional overflow parking spots
in the neighborhood where those homes have the smaller
garages? What if, even if it came down to
taking one lot out to add way more overflow parking?
Because I think that ultimately would be cheaper
than a full redesign of ones that are already the
2-story ones. So I'm just wondering if that would make
a big enough difference for my fellow council members.
I've got some questions for you. What's the difference in the width of the garage
from your 3, your 3-story model?
So the, the width is the same. It's 20.08
feet. And the reason for that is the lots are already platted
and we can't make— and all of the utilities are stubbed to them.
That leads to my next question. And so basically we've given up the storage space
behind that was there in the 3-story. We've gone with a
longer garage per se that will enable trucks garbage
cans and even some SUVs to be in there, but we haven't really gained
any ground on the width of the garage.
That's correct. One thing we have gained on though is the original— when
we did the development agreement, the 2 stories did not have a
basement, and now the, the design with the 2 stories has a 520
square foot unfinished basement. So the 21 Townhomes
that we're proposing to have this 2-story design with the larger garage,
it'd be 520 times 21, about 11,000
square feet of— I actually did the calculation,
let me look— 11,000 square feet of unfinished
basement storage space that the 3 stories would not have because they're
slab on grade. So my, my concern is width.
I think you should probably remember that from our last conversation.
They need to be able to get out of the car once it's in there,
especially when it's snowing, raining, or whatever. And if they
pull in at the same time, it really is gonna be the finagling that we
tend to see where everybody gets out and somebody backs the car in to get
out. Do you feel like that there's any flexibility to
move that to a 21.5-foot width inside?
Where if it was a paper lot and it was just
kind of a concept, might be possible, but where the roads are
paved and all the utilities are in and all of the— You'd end up losing
the use of those for stuff. The lots, it would be— I'm
less concerned about the parking. I mean, it's a townhouse community. I mean, there's only
so many places you can put parking. I think that you've, you've shown,
at least on this design, that there's space to be
able to park on the driveway. You can fit inside the garage. I think
that's the intent, at least from My perspective, the width is a
bit of a concern. I don't think we gained any ground on that, and I
don't know that I'm one way or the other not
having the space behind the garage. I think they'll likely use that
for a storage space more than they would use the basement for that. The basement
just ends up being a catch-all, but that's a decision you
guys make. I don't care about that stuff. That's really not us. That's that's going
to be market driven and whether people agree. with that. I think for me,
what we were looking for as far as the parking, I think you've accomplished that
in my perspective. Um, I, I do like
that the floor plan is, uh, a little more palatable
to the people who want to buy it and don't have smaller floors.
So for me, I don't, I don't really have any problems with this.
Great, thank you. I'm, I'm along the lines of what Council
Member Wright's asking, is that if we're giving up space And taking a
3-car and going to a 2-car, if you can improve the 2 cars
in the other areas that were smaller and you can make those 2 cars larger,
then I would be open to looking at that for sure. So if that's
something you could bring back, I would be open to looking at that. Okay,
let's go back to the other page. So you only mentioned a couple. So what
they've both said, you mentioned that these ones aren't done, but also these ones.
So we're looking at this row and this row that still possibly could
be adjusted. That's what you're asking? Yeah.
And I, again, I don't wanna commit to it. I need to find out.
Well, yeah, I was just out there, I think. Could you state your name for
the record? Oh, sorry. Taylor Keyes with Element Homes
on the sales part of it. I was out there. I believe they've got
this blue. You need to point at it. Here's one of the blue that you're
using. This one's getting backfilled. That one's getting backfilled, and I think they've
dug here. And I guess what I— we'll have to look
at and see what's been submitted, right? But if I'm hearing what you're saying is
go back and say, well, what buildings could be on the table?
So whether that's a function of we just have to say, okay, here's how many
have been pulled, here's what's on the schedule, and then we come back and say,
well, we could do this building or not do this building and kind of see
what that— if that fits what you're looking for. Ultimately, I think the goal here
is to gain more than just the additional 20— Well,
this would be 21 instead of 20. Yeah, and 20, right.
So I think I'm hearing what you're saying is you
would like it to be a greater benefit if we're gonna do this. Well,
it might not be the exact same
as these other units you're talking about here, but at least bigger than what's already
designed as a trade-off. Sure. 'Cause I don't know what the design is
on those. I don't remember. Well, so we had the— so around the perimeter there,
it's the typical 2-story with the garage that was originally approved,
the smaller garage, right? And then we have this 2-story with
the bigger garage. And so the question would just be what units could
we— So it would be easier to do the ones around
the outside just because there's— There's more space. Space towards the boundary.
On these ones, it would be taking up, know, the grass open space
or going into the trail. But so that's something— it sounds like if you can
make that happen, you'll probably get a yes. I, I think we can
take that feedback and get back with the team, and then we can bring it.
Zach, you're going on or something?
Okay. So yeah, I'm gonna— I, I would agree with Brett and Craig.
If we can get a little more value there, come back with that, I think
that'd be fine. Okay, so I'm going to sum up what I've heard,
and if I missed something, let me know. These units on this outside potentially
adding a little bit of garage space.
These ones weren't on the table anyway, so it's just these ones out here.
Maybe some additional parking.
These ones are all built on the south boundary. No, yeah, I was just pointing
out the parking here. So these ones get increased a little bit
in exchange for these ones getting decreased. And then a potential additional
parking similar to this guest parking somewhere. So I
was zooming in on the tabulations when the civil engineer designed
it. The required parking was 378 and the provided
parking was 386, and we had them add parking basically
everywhere that they could. You know, there's a lot of places where it's just 2
parking spots wide because it's in between the So,
and I heard Councilmember Wood say that he was less concerned about that. So is
parking— is more of just a maybe? There's just not a place to
put it. Like, if they've already got the footprints planned, I mean,
you're going to have to start giving up units. I don't think that's
a feasible solution. So the parking's— we're okay with the parking, then it's
just getting some added benefit in these outside units. And I think
then, then we'd consider the— is that good? Anything else?
Councilmember Clark, is that kind of— is that good feedback? Do you have
any questions? Yes, it is. And, and there's a handful of places that
don't have the parking space, but I believe that's where we put the transformers.
So, um, yeah, we'll go back and, and get with
Element. I know this one, the building permits are already submitted and,
and it's going to be dug soon, but these ones around the outside,
we'll get with both the structural engineer and the surveyor and
the planning department and see You know, on both the replatting and
reengineering, and see how quick that that could potentially happen. And thank you
for working with our staff on the replat versus the lot line adjustment.
I mean, if they're asking you to do that, I'm grateful that you're willing to
entertain that. Yeah, and the reason we did the lot line adjustment on this one
just is our surveyor said it's faster. But looking at
how much work it takes to get it updated
with the county, I can see why. The staff prefers the replat, so we're
happy to do that. Okay, thank you for— Do you have any other questions?
Okay, I think we're good. Thank you very much. Appreciate you coming in. Thank you.
Getting through that. All right, so next item,
1B, is a discussion about Healthy Utah Communities.
This is something that the council, an initiative we've— we talk about
every year when we're in St. George, and I believe in Salt Lake. Um,
I know the deadline's coming up, so Steve is gonna lead
this, tell us what we gotta do,
get some direction. I know the Community Services
Board also worked on this, I believe. And if there are
any other questions, go ahead.
Thank you, Mayor. We'll see if it comes up here. It's not coming up.
Okay.
I may have to go hang out in Dave's spot over there. We've got help
coming from the back row. Should be
as easy as plugging in and going. I'll give an intro then.
Yeah, we always go to these conferences in the fall and the spring, and then
we hear about all these communities that are doing great things related to
health and food and mental health.
And active living. And then we're always like, why aren't we
doing this? Let's get going. And so Natalie Winterton actually
did some work on this last year to get us going. And the
city council last year approved a resolution to
authorize the mayor to sign a letter and start the application process.
And then we were lacking in a couple of areas that we couldn't fulfill
back then. But now that we have our community services board in place, that can
act as our health coalition.
We hope that that will work for it.
The Get Healthy Utah organization, the 501 Get Healthy
Utah, put together this
community healthy— Healthy
Utah Community Designation specifically for towns and cities.
And our size requires that we
implement 3, that we have already implemented
3 action items, 3 strategies within
3 different categories. And the first is active
living, and then there's,
it's related to food services, access to healthy
food, and then— Housing. The last is mental health. And so
at the request of the council, I started working with our Community Services
Board, with Jesse and Charlotte and the board, and we
talked in a couple of different meetings. We had other priorities pop up, so we've
been talking about it for probably a few meetings, but this last meeting we really
dove in and chose some strategies that
we've already implemented, and then— What are those strategies? Also recommended
some 3 additional strategies that we need to propose
to implement over the next 3 years. I can
just plug in over there if we need to. Yeah, it's probably my computer.
Okay, hang tight for a moment.
Okay, we'll try this one, Lacey, if that— and if it's my computer,
it won't pop up, so we will— yeah,
all right, great.
Okay, so passed the resolution last year,
requires 9 implemented strategies and 3 strategies within each of those categories.
And so this just gives you an idea. They have a list of, hey,
here are some recommended strategies within the active living category.
There's a bunch of different things. We can go back to that if, if you
want. Same with access to healthy food and
mental health. And so the strategies
that the board chose to recommend to have
shown that we implemented already or are currently maintaining.
First was to organize a free or low-cost fitness event for your community,
and we do the annual Turkey Trot every year. It's on Thanksgiving
morning, brings out thousands of people. They love
it. That's one of our event staff's favorite
events. And then second was to create an active transportation
plan or update an existing one. So we do have an existing bike and pedestrian
master plan that needs some more updating soon.
But you, council, also approved the off-street trails
master plan just last meeting. And then third,
improve physical activity among the youth by promoting a physical activity resource
program or best practice in schools. The example they gave on
their website is, for example, safe routes to schools. And so we talked about
that. And the schools all create a plan
and then the city helps as much as we can to implement that.
And it's not just having sidewalks and
trails to the school, but it also includes from the school side other
trainings and practices,
activities to help encourage kids to bike and walk to school.
So that's the active living. There were other options
there as well, but those are the 3 that the board recommended.
Second is access to healthy food. So the first was host a community
program to promote healthy eating. And our library
has had a seed exchange that's for vegetables and other seeds that they've
had for quite a while. And that's pretty popular in there.
And then improve access to emergency food by establishing a food pantry
or program or improving an existing one. I think you're all
aware of the food pantry that we have in the library, the emergency food pantry
that's, that's right there in the entryway, and that's been well
utilized by our community. And then establish a farmers market
that accepts SNAP benefits. I've been told that that's what our farmers
market does, that we partner with that group and, and they're there every
Saturday morning during the summer at Quarry Ride Park. And then we've also
included the farmers market in some of our major events recently as well.
And then last is mental health. First one was
we decided to use the other category, and it's to promote a program
to foster encouragement, connection, and hope across the community. And so the council
passed the resolution to become
the first Believer City with the Show Me a Sign organization.
And then we have that event as well, the Motivational Mile.
Second is host a recurring community event that promotes social connection among
a vulnerable demographic. And so one of our vulnerable demographics
is our senior citizens, and the council's been great to support
them with funding and with a location that we expanded
fairly recently. And then they have all of their events
that they participate in. And then third is implement a strategy to
promote safe use of guns. And we do provide free gun locks at our
library and also can promote that
on social media and to our residents. So those are, those are the 9
strategies that were recommended that we include. And,
and then the next section is to, is to show the data
and look at, look at the data that's out there and be able to determine,
okay, what are our greatest needs as a community so that we can implement 3
new strategies over the next 3 years. We didn't have
time or take the time to go through this in detail with the Community Services
Board. They did recommend some strategies, which I'll show you,
but I wanted to show you some of the research from these, these 3
locations that are recommended.
Public Health Indicator-Based Information System,
which is a— which is on the Department of Health and Human Services website.
The Utah Healthy Places Index, which is more of a map system, and you
go in and it shows some It breaks up basically by
tax areas, breaks up the city and
the whole state. And then Utah State University Well-Being
Survey, which they just barely released the results from that.
So all I did here was include some of the areas that we're
either doing poorly in our community or close
to. Or that maybe I was concerned about.
And so one is the fair— is fair or poor general health. And it's
a percentage of adults aged 18 and older who reported fair or
poor general health. And in our community, that was 16.6%.
That's higher than the Utah average, lower than the US average.
That was a little concerning. 7 or more days of poor mental
health in the past 30 days.
21% of our residents are adults.
That's under the state average and the national average, but still concerning. And then
vegetables consumed 3 or more times per day, just showing do you have a good
healthy mix of food available in our— where there's
a red exclamation point, that means we're lower or worse
than the Utah average.
Another was high blood pressure or high blood cholesterol.
Ours was quite a bit higher than the Utah average.
And hypertension, doctor-diagnosed hypertension
as well was higher.
The recommended amount of aerobic physical activity, and so
recommended amount for adults it looks like is 150
minutes per week of moderate-intensity or 75 minutes of vigorous intensity.
And it says we're about in line
with Utah, but we're about 9% lower than the Utah
average. Adult obesity and
overweight or obese adults, ours was
slightly higher than Utah in
both of those categories.
And then how well are our female
adults looking ahead and planning
for mammograms and Pap tests and others? And our rates
were quite a bit lower than Utah.
And almost done with these, but the suicide rate is lower
than the Utah average, but obviously it's one of those zero fatalities kind
of number that you don't want. to be high at all, if possible. So that's
concerning. And then depression prevalence as well.
Percentage of adults who have been diagnosed with a
depressive disorder, major depression, minor depression.
Ours is lower than Utah average, but still 23%
of our adult population. And then on the wellbeing survey,
For Utah State, the average rating
of personal and community well-being. So they rate, they rank each
of those. And the last time they did this survey,
they're comparing it to the 2020 results. And so our numbers have
gone down on both of those, it looks like.
And well-being domain importance. How important are the following
categories to your overall personal well-being? And they have quite a few categories
there on the left. Mental health is, and safety and
security are the most important to our residents, 96%.
Living standards, family life close behind, physical health,
environmental quality, leisure time, and then it goes down from there.
So just showing those are really important, even if we're doing fairly
well in some of those categories, they're very important. So we should keep
putting efforts towards improving those areas. How connected
do you feel to Eagle Mountain as a community? Looks like most of
the respondents at least felt average
or below connected to the community or
as a community. And then inclusion for individuals with disabilities.
How well does Eagle Mountain include individuals with disabilities in social,
recreational, and cultural activities? 43% probably didn't
have anyone or know anyone that was disabled.
The rest looks like somewhat, quite well, somewhere in between.
There's always more we can do, of course, with that.
So the board,
again, they didn't go through all of that data, but they recommended 3
strategies, that we destigmatize mental illness through a community
campaign or event. And there were several events talked
about. The high school is involved
in a suicide walk, suicide prevention walk.
And then add wayfinding signage for trails that provide both time and distance for
routes, or maybe conduct a messaging campaign to promote
physical activity in the community. And third
is another category, which is to implement adaptive sports and
recreation programs. Or host a recurring community event that
promotes social connection among a vulnerable demographic, which could be our disabled
population. So I know our Jason Hall and our recreation
group have been very interested in implementing some sort of adaptive program
that's that's more robust than what we do currently.
And currently, we just kind of combine with
the rest of the cities in the in Utah County and
Participants that are disabled, their families have to drive them all over the
place to participate. So one day they'll be in Lehi,
and one day they'll be in Eagle Mountain, and another day they'll be down in
Orem or somewhere. And so it'd be nice if they could stay here and continue
to participate. Steve, there's actually a woman that has been at the farmers
market that is promoting the Special Olympics in Eagle Mountain. She's trying to bring a
chapter here. And so I just want to put that on the radar of the
Community Services Board. I would love to see us find a way to help them
as a vulnerable demographic and see if we can incorporate them into some of our
city events. Yeah, that's a great idea. Yeah, she stopped by our booth at the,
at the farmers market. We all talked to her. That's a great idea. Um,
these were other options that were discussed or thrown out there as
possibilities: establish a community garden, We do
have a couple board members looking into that. Develop a new walking/biking trail
or add to an existing one. Hey Steve, just, I wanna jump back to that
community garden. Is that possible to do that in multiple locations?
Absolutely. I mean, with the size that we are, it'd be great to have that
in a bunch of locations. Could I, just for context,
I know he's wiggling over there about this, but Brad, we already
have some places, right, that you've, that we've identified. Water run there and they kind
of get run down. Do you want to speak to what's kind of already
available and why they're not maybe used,
or at least speak to that for a minute? Yeah,
there's one spot over in the Pioneer subdivision that has
previously been used for a garden scenario,
and we actually had some outside entities come in with,
with some residents in that area. We ran
water to the site. It still exists. After about
3 seasons of trying to plant it, the garden just never took off and it
kind of failed. And so we haven't seen a successful campaign
with that yet. If we could get to a successful campaign,
then I think we start with 1 or 2 and find out
what works, and then we can expand on it from there.
Yeah, one of our ideas was to do that at the senior center, possibly,
if we have enough room, where the seniors love The idea of
gardening and helping out with that, maybe they take some ownership of it.
So is that something that they could— it's all kind of ready to go if
the Community Service Board looks into that, or if they— is that something that they
could pursue, or is it the
ground location that's no good? I'm sure that
there would need to be some amendment to it to— I mean, it's been sitting
in a state of— not in a garden state for several
years, so There's probably some prep and whatnot, but yeah, there is a water
connection already in that location. Send a pan or a location so that we can
look into that. It's right next to Pioneer Park on Silver Spur Way.
But yeah, we can, we can give them some info.
I was thinking maybe there's an opportunity to do some teaching how
to start from where it's at, because a lot of people probably are in similar
situations. Perhaps that's a volunteer thing that we can bring some of our hobby
farmers in to teach, and we could use that as the teaching tool to be
able to create our very first one that way. There's a chance,
you know, Jen Corrington that runs the market, she's a big gardener and in
that space. Maybe she could help do some classes. I don't know, something like
that. Yeah, I think the key is to get some community members that are passionate
about it and that are willing to continue and help and help with the trainings
and other things.
Some other options, messaging campaign to promote healthy eating,
offer suicide prevention trainings for individuals or organizations,
and beautify, enhance, or create a section of the community that promotes social
gathering and connection. Those are all kind of options that they
list that we threw out there. And so
really, I guess, really what I'm asking today is,
Do you support the 9 strategies that are shown up there, and then either
these 3, or tell me which 3 you want to pursue over the
next 3 years, and then we'll include that in the application and have the mayor
sign that and submit it tonight. We'll get that
in tonight because they gave us an extension to be able to get it in
today. If we want to be— and we don't have to,
obviously, we can wait and take our time
if we want. if you're not ready, but otherwise we'll get it in tonight and
then be recognized at the September ULCT conference.
I'm a yes. Yeah, I think we should move forward.
Yeah, I think the initiatives are great. I like what you've done
to hit each of the 9 things. I'd love for us to— I think that
there's maybe a 2 birds, one stone opportunity. I think there's an opportunity with
some of our undeveloped open space that has weeds
where perhaps we could identify some of those for a garden that becomes useful
to the people who live around it.
Yeah, I mean, I'm supportive of this, and frankly,
I want to thank you, Steve, for your leadership and the Community
Services Board for their willingness to kind of dive in on this. So thank
you. Yeah, I support this.
I would like to see this application. We've been waiting for years to get this
submitted, so like, I want to get it done. Ditto. Yeah, I remember the
very first time I ever went to the ULCT. I'm like, why aren't we on
the list? And so we've been looking at this for a long time, but,
uh, it just needs a signature on the application for us to get recognized.
Just wanted to make sure that we're all on the same page. And then lastly,
is there any other questions from council for either Steve, or I know 2
of our Community Service Board members? Any input, questions? Good.
Okay, I think that's— that'll work. Thank you very much.
All right, we'll move on
to item 1C. This is a discussion, uh, I know we came into the office
a little while ago and spoke with Roger. Come on up. And,
uh, with concerns about clear lines of sight for
their business.
Turn the— turn that mic on.
Does it— I'll pull it up for you.
If everything's random, turn the mic. There's a button.
There's a button. There you go, it's on now. Okay,
we good?
Last time I was able to talk to the city council was in 2020.
I don't know if any of you were here. Melissa was, I know for sure.
Jared was. And, um, that's when we were moving into
this facility and coming in as the— to buy land for
our facility. As you can see, we started building our facility
in 2021, right at the beginning of 2021.
We are a satellite communications company,
and we moved from South Jordan down here. And one of the reasons
was to to be able to get enough land to be able to do what
we needed to do. And so, as you can tell from the facility,
we do satellite communications. We are a hosting facility
where the ground and the look angles are very important
to us. And so, that's one of the reasons why we're here
is to be able to help you realize that we help other companies
to be able to provide communications from voice,
video, streaming, whatever the case may be, internet data.
We provide that communications for these folks. The thing
that's happening today in the industry is,
rather than going into a lot of detail, there's a
satellite coverage called GEO, which is Greater Earth
Orbit, that goes way out there, and LEO. Many of you have heard
of Starlink. That's LEO. That's lower.
And so we are hosting a lot of lower Earth orbit
satellite communication facilities. And so our contracts
that we are developing now, because we came in, we built,
we went through this whole process, are now coming to fruition,
and they're starting to see the value of our facility and the look
angles that we have in our particular area. And so that
kind of gives you an idea as one of the reasons why we came here.
We can go to the next slide, or can I do that?
Uh, no, you'll have to— Okay, no problem. This is great. Okay,
so that kind of talks about what we've done. When we came in, we had
our open house with Melissa, came in with the Chamber of Commerce. We did our
open house in November of 2023. Um,
as I mentioned to you, we were looking for a location. Now here
again, I'm telling you what I remember when we came into this
facility is that the area that we were looking at
was zoned as light industrial, okay,
which for us was very important to us because of the height
restrictions of those particular areas. It's important for us with
a lower look angle facility to have a 10-degree look angle,
and so that of, of 360 degrees. As the
facilities were coming into the north, LKL, I believe it is,
the The drywall company that came into
the north of us, the Saltwater Fitness, Salt Lake Fitness
company that came in, they were just— they met perfect. That was fine. Their buildings
were great. Everything was the right height. But now we're starting to
learn a little bit more. If we go to the next slide.
Some of those that we're finding and that we're learning about
and what we're seeing is that some of the zoning has been changed. And now
this could be true, it could be wrong. I'm not positive or not. But what
we're seeing on the maps is that the facility right to the east
of us, right next to our property to the east between us
and Arrow Construction, which is Willie's place,
is now industrial. Which means if somebody came in there and wanted to
build a 5-story building, that could be detrimental to
me. All right, just because of the look angle of a 50-foot
type building for my particular satellites
that they're looking to the side. We've also learned that QTS,
of course, bought the property to the west, which is zoned agricultural now
but could also go industrial. All right, if they are
too close to us on that side,
that could potentially be a problem as well too. Now, if they built the
size of Meta, a building that, you know, is only 25
to 50 feet or 25 to 35 feet,
that would be okay. But if— and then if they're offset far enough
off, that would be okay too. Does that make sense,
everybody? Just that 360 is what we're looking at. And then of course,
what really, what really caused our attention is when all of a sudden we
saw construction, you know, equipment happening to our south. We found
out that the city was doing some there on the water treatment facility,
which made us a little bit nervous. Then they brought in some construction trailers.
We did an analysis where we could look to see over those
construction trailers. We're fine there. But if somebody wanted
to build some buildings there, particularly with the berm that is there,
that could be an issue for us. Just to be able to see over top
of that, because where our property line is on that 10 acres that we have
is critical for us to be able to have that 10-degree look angle.
So that kind of gives you an idea where we're located. Pony Express is the
one that's right there on the right-hand side of the square. That's where our property
is. The new property to the west of us, that green area, is the
agricultural QTS property as well too.
And so our biggest concern right now is to bring the
council as well as the city just the awareness of the fact that When
we came here, we were under— with the understanding that it was light industrial
and that we couldn't get those buildings. That's one of the main reasons why we
came. And so we're here now. All these are starting to come in.
We have numerous contracts now that are coming in with—
which are multimillion-dollar contracts. And if I have— if
I come across a problem where I can't— they can't go 10-degree, they're going
to go somewhere else to do their work. And so that's all I'm asking
for at this particular time. We can go to the next slide.
Is that's really kind of what we're asking for is that we either
look at changing the zoning of those areas around us or we
look at options to be able to just help us out a little bit
just to scoot them back or to allow it so high or
whatever the case may be. But we just needed to bring this to your attention
so that you knew where our concern was.
Any questions? Uh, one question I have is how far
out into these properties does
that angle go? Where— do
you see what I'm saying? Yep. So there's probably like so many feet.
This is Rusty Lake. It's like a property rights issue, right? Like somebody
buys land next to you and what you're asking us is to kind
of restrict their ability Or impede their ability to build on their property. Right.
Which I understand what you're saying. And what I'm kind of wondering is
nothing has been built. Right. As that gets developed and planned
out, could there be a partnership where— Absolutely. We don't put the building on this
side, we put it on the other side. And I'm not even sure as a
council how we can restrict or zone the
airspace above their property. Right. Like to
keep that in sight. I have a different question. Councilmember Hughes, my question
is really this. Recognizing that this sounds like
it's a consistent problem for you, sounds like this is probably not the first time
you've run into this, I'm guessing. No. So it may be
one of the reasons why you relocated to Eagle Mountain in the first place.
Exactly. And so trying
to understand that, I guess my question is, I'm putting myself in your
shoes and saying, if I'm this business owner, how do I mitigate these things,
and can I? And so I'm going to ask a really dumb question because I
don't know the answer, and hopefully you'll be able to make me a little smarter.
That's a heavy lift, but some people have succeeded.
Sure. Okay, so it's a challenge I'm going to give you. Is it possible
to raise your satellites up and then to have that angle be down so that
if you do find yourself in close proximity to a 50-foot building that
you can still clear it and have that low To a degree,
yes. The answer to that question is yes, but there's—
you can only go up so high. Do you have any other insight on that,
Rusty? Just on height of the— And the only reason I asked that question is
what you're asking us to do is to restrict adjacent property owners from
being able to petition or ask to do what they see
as their highest and best use on their property, and that's a real wrestle for
us to do that. For me, I'm going to speak just for myself,
um, but I, I want to be cognizant of the fact that there may be
some impacts that, that, that are coming to you that you're not warm and fuzzy
about. But I don't see this as a lot different than those who come
in and say the builder took away my view and I thought I was going
to have this view in perpetuity. We don't buy the view, we buy the,
the ground that we build on. And so I, I, I'm just
I'm trying to kind of wrestle through this and say, if I'm you and I'm
dealing with these impacts and I can't retard that or restrict
it, and I don't know if we can or can't, my sense is we probably
can't and that we probably shouldn't. And if that's the
case, then I'm saying, well, how could we help mitigate it? Do we as a
council need to be willing to say, look, if you're going to lift those things
up 20 feet in the air so that you can still get that low
angle, maybe that's where we could help you in, in creating a,
an exception to perhaps other restrictions that you're dealing with. So that's
an area that perhaps I could weigh into and say maybe we can find a
path forward to help you with that. Right. And I
would just add to that, I, I agree with Councilmember Wright. Have you had
some good faith discussions with some of those property owners?
I'm imagining they're aware of the issue. They're moving right into a satellite
company. I think we have somebody from— or we had somebody from Meta
here earlier, but have you started those conversations as
they're contemplating how to structure their facilities?
Yeah, just for the record, Rusty Layton with LVISAT.
No, we have not had those conversations, mainly because some
of the land obviously isn't developed yet and the land to the east isn't
sold. It's it's vacant. Excuse me,
vacant. We're looking at options for
the the land of the east with some investors and and potential projects
to just purchase that land, and that kind of eliminates all of it. And I
think the core issue is that when we decided
to come out because we looked at multiple locations up by the airport,
out in Payson, things like that. But Eagle Mountain, when we
we discussed with the council back. then, the zoning was light
industrial. And I, and I understand the impeding,
you know, like you don't want your view to change and things like that,
but it was our understanding that this would remain light industrial.
So we didn't have any issues for our long-term contracts,
you know. But then we, we find out recently that, I think it was 2024,
that overlays and other things were changed in those to industrial.
And whether that was because of the business coming in— Right.
You know, we just felt as kind of previous tenants under the light industrial that
I don't know if we want to refer to it as stepped
on a little bit, things like that. But really, it so
we have on this slide thirty-foot and fifty-foot buildings, and I kind of
ran some of the math on this so you could kind of determine from the
point of an antenna. I went off a five-foot bottom of
reflector angle. At a 7-degree, not a 10-degree, but a
7-degree look angle and how far that setback would have to be around.
And a lot of our antennas, they're not like right on our property
line. They're in 40, 50 feet. Some of these will
be a little higher on focal point in the center. So that math changes a
little bit. And I also added a buffer for RF radiation.
Not that there's a significant amount, but it does have to be taken into consideration
if In the distance, you have a 5-story building, and we do it
so precisely that our transmit path goes right
to the top of that. You get somebody walking on top, there's potential for
radiation to that person. It's just something that we have to work
with the FCC and adjoining surrounding companies
and buildings when we're doing this. Those distances
are kind of what we're asking for the areas around us. If it's If it's
rezoned to light industrial, that kind of goes away. But if it can't be,
that we work with the future builders, whether that's QTS
to the west, the city to the south, or whoever
buys the property to our east, that those plans,
they can still build the building they want. We just kind of work with
them to say, here's the distance to these satellites where you would be.
We need an 85-foot setback. Thank you. From the antennas that
are existing, say, on whatever corner of our property. It's not
so much that it prevents people from coming
in. It's more just we work with the
future development if we can't rezone that area back
to light industrial to what it, like, so it's still light industrial across the street
to the north. It's more just our little strip the
2 plots just to the east and then kind of south
there for the city water treatment. If that—
any questions on what I've said? I would say this. I think there's value in
you raising this and helping us becoming aware of it, 'cause I frankly wasn't.
And so I think at least by having an awareness as we entertain some
of those other things, we can certainly have a discussion and see if there's
a willingness on on those who come before us to partner
and to work, to try and work through that. We can't guarantee that, but if
we're aware of it, we can at least raise it. So I think there's value
in you bringing this to our attention. If I could
just— my name is Corey Wofford. I'm the president of our company here.
I just have one comment, and that is, as we sat and
listened to the 2 previous presentations, the first one was about
the size of a garage. And you are all concerned about
the size of the garage. Seems to me that if you can be concerned
about the size of a garage, you could be concerned about our look angles,
is all I'm simply saying. So I'm just throwing that
out. So we, we would appreciate your appreciation, your,
uh— I think the challenge though is that you're asking us to tell somebody
on their land to scoot back to accommodate for your land that
you didn't I think that's where I'm struggling with this.
With the view angles, I'm curious, why 10 acres? Why not
50? So that you could centralize your view angles and protect your
investment in the future no matter what was built around you. Well, if I needed
an 85-foot setback from my current property line, I'd be in negotiations with
those adjacent property owners to buy 85 feet so that I could secure my sightline.
I mean, that's the kind of stuff I would be doing. I think that the
problem is is they're going to come back to us and say, uh, they don't
own the, the airspace or the land that we have purchased, and they've spent
millions on that just like you have. Having a council
that comes in after the fact is not really to your benefit because we didn't
have the conversations. And if these things aren't dealt with in a master
development agreement, what really can we do?
Not change the light industrial. That's what we came in on.
It's Light industrial. It's RTI, I believe.
Isn't that Sweetwater Overlay Zone though? That's what I think. The one there
is. It's the RTI there, right? Yes,
it's RTI. I have some things to
share with you as well to kind of add some more information. Let's see what
you have to say.
Let me add a few thoughts here.
We'll skip to some of this. So looking across the street to
the west, this is the site plan for the QTS expansion.
And let me see if I can zoom in here. Yeah. Why is it doing
that? I'm gonna try to zoom
in there. So you
can see, The site's just across
the— it's right here. And the distance
from the property line to the edge of this retention basin
is 320 feet. You've got
a whole right-of-way. I don't think they've got a lot of concerns.
That's what's going to be built is the retention basin.
Do you know what the height of the building is, Brandon? Checking on
that, I think they're under 50. I'm not 100%.
Actually, we were in the process of looking that up.
If I have that before we're done, I'll let you know.
But we've got we've
got a facility that's that's kind of
built in some buffers with its adjacent neighbors there
on the to.
Brandon, can I ask where Magnolia is at
on that drawing? It's right
here. It's Virtual Drive. That's Virtual Drive is what Magnolia
is? Yes, Magnolia. Okay.
You've had, as far as development to the south
of the property, you've had the new tertiary
treatment building that was built over here. It's possible
that our city could build additional buildings to
the south. I was— Brad was just checking
the elevation. The grades to the south on
our property actually are a little bit higher.
In fact, Brad, I think you said that the grade where
We're on our property may be close to the height of the satellite dishes now,
so that that is something to consider.
That that land to the south, and here's a zoning
map. It's it's in the LMD.
Most of this, so to the west of the is the ag
zone with the RTI, except for this piece
right here where we have our. where we
have our ponds there. The rest of it over here is
in the light manufacturing distribution
zone or the business park
light industry. That's what our park— that's what our zoning map's
telling us along. And you can see the Sweetwater overlay.
Okay. Ag zone,
the height there is pretty low. Well, the issue is the
RTI. RTI will let you go up to 50 feet. However,
it does have the ability to go above that provided
the right approvals are given. Business, park, light industrial,
there is an issue with our zoning map in that the truth is
that business park light industrial zone is actually a
land use designation and not a zone. But essentially
what I'm getting at is the light industry zoning
that you thought that was there, it's essentially
still there. I don't know that the zone— what's changed is
the RTI zone overlay, which allows you
to go up to 50 feet and virtually everything in this whole So the entire
image that I'm showing you is now in the RTI overlay zone
with the exception of our ponds
right here, the parcel with our ponds.
Are those ponds right at the bottom there?
Yeah, circled in blue. Go to the other ones. Are those ponds
going away? No. They retain?
Yep, they'll be
retained. It's possible
that our land here and the public works property,
it very well could be rezoned to the public facilities zone,
which would be a 35-foot height.
But again,
you've got that grade difference between your property and
the city's. Sweetwater overlay zone
is something else we haven't talked a ton about, but it doesn't actually
have its own height requirement. It has—
it basically relies on the bases, the zoning,
or the height of the base zone, which again is basically
a light industrial zone as you know it.
Mm-hmm. And here's the
current future land use map designations. Most of its business,
Park Light Industries. So I
think that your neighbors to the west,
again, have been taking a look
at trying to mitigate impacts by putting
retention basins and so forth and creating a
separation from you. So I don't think you've got a lot of concern with QTS.
I'm—it's possible. I guess the city could build a taller
building, but I mean, I don't think it's super common in a public
works facility to have really tall buildings.
The other thing too—you and I talked about the idea that these parcels
off to the east are land that's undeveloped, and it is
possible to to to consider acquiring that.
to provide yourself a buffer.
And then across the street, you've seen some
of the development that's occurring. You've got the LKL facility
and then the Salt— I'm forgetting the name of that
building. The Salt— Salt City Fitness. Salt City
Fitness or whatever. And so I think you're kind of getting a taste
of the heights that are— that you should expect
across the street. So I'm trying to help you get an idea
of what's being proposed,
what's possible. And I think there are some things that
I'd be concerned about and some maybe a little bit, but I
think a lot of things that probably should give you a little bit of hope.
It's knowing that QTS is taking care to
set their development back quite a ways from your property line,
knowing that— That's huge. I didn't know that before we came in. So this was—
that's good information to know. I think, like you said, if that's true
with what they're putting in there and stuff, that will give us enough room to
be able to make that happen.
Is there somebody— yeah, sorry.
So is there somebody with QTS that we could get information
and swap so that we can actually discuss that in a little more detail,
and I could sit down and do the math with it and just make sure
that— I've got a guy named Mitchell Bisbara that
you can talk with. Okay, I'll get you his contact information. Thank you, because we're
more than willing to talk with anybody and everybody that we need to, to be
able to help us work together on this. That's what it's about, being good neighbors,
right? Absolutely, absolutely. Our biggest thing is that particularly
We understood that, you know, to the west of us, we were a little concerned.
We figured we could work with all of you all with the south.
We figured we can— we've got— hopefully we have some camaraderie
here that you loved us enough because you let us come in and you knew
what we were doing. We want to see you succeed. Exactly. And so we appreciate
that. On the east side of it, I'm also talking with, you know,
the development group, you know, the RE/MAX group, And I
think his name is Richard Farnsworth, who's selling that property
to the east. I've already been in conversation with him
and looking at talking with him to see that, because I do have some potential
folks that might want to pick that up earlier than later. So we can check
on that to see what they're doing, and he's keeping me abreast as to who's
interested in that property as well too. So we are working on that
as well. So I think it's good for Just for us to be aware of
the issue, just as plans come forward, that that's in our heads
and we're just aware of it. So that's good. That was my main purpose,
was to let you folks know where we're at, what we're doing.
We appreciate you very much for this opportunity to be able to
bring this to your attention. We thank Brandon for coming out and seeing
the facility and looking over things and all that to be able to
help us out with that. So just one brief question. So are
you able to Raise the elevation of your satellites? To some—
well, with some of them, yes.
But, but to, you know, so much, I mean, I'm thinking maybe
10 to 15 feet. I mean, but there's
some of them that are smaller, all right, that have a 17 by 17 pad,
all right. But then to be able to build that up a little bit,
that could be tough. It could be tough. Could it be done? Possibly.
I'd much rather work with the neighbors and work with folks to be able
to help it so we could just stay at the elevation we're at. It'd be
much less cost.
We turned off your mic.
Okay. No, there is a question over here, Brad. Just for
context on our site, it looks like there's,
from the top of our pond to the road that the
satellite company's on, there's like a 10 to 15-foot offset
in grade. Right. So I don't think we have any intent with
our buildings to build anything more than a 2-story.
Right. But the 250-foot
Just for context, from the property line, that basically takes
in almost our whole buildable footprint for our treatment plant facility upgrade,
and we don't have a big option to move that. So it's
good for us to be aware with this, and we'll have to work with you
through this process. I just want that to be clear and on the record.
Are they looking at right to the south right there, or— we
kind of told that it might be a little bit more north and So the
phase that we're on will be north and east, but as time goes on,
there will be more that will be built, and that's where that treatment plant
is gonna expand, just so that it's on your record and on your radar.
Okay. I just wanna speak
to that 250-foot number. So that's— I don't wanna
necessarily use the term arbitrary, but there is a buffer in there that
I kinda threw in just Again, it's at like a 7-degree,
kind of a lower kind of 5-foot offset.
So that's something that we can discuss a little more. And our antenna systems,
there's 2 of them that are already placed now, and the pads for 2 more
are there so that you'll, if you were to be at that construction trailer,
you would kind of see where they're at. So they sit in about 40 feet
already on our property. So that takes it down to 210.
And then we figure in some more like where any potential building will go.
I anticipate that number being smaller than 250.
That's just kind of a safe zone that I put
in at first just to kind of give an idea of where we're at.
But Brad, I appreciate you letting us know that because we do need to visit
on that if there's any way that— I mean, those— that berm
that's there, I kind of thought that berm was there just because
of the water treatment plant You know, the ponds were there. I thought that that
possibly could come down if there's a build that was going to happen
there. And I'm not saying that it can't come down. There's probably potential
that some of it can come down, but I just don't want to set the
expectation that everything's going to be at that ground grade because
we already have a lot of infrastructure and a lot of it's going to run
off elevations. And so we'll just have to probably coordinate with you offline.
Okay, sounds great. Appreciate it. I did just
want to point out that these buildings to the north of you, they're all— this
one looks like it's a little less than 24 feet. This one
is typically— looks like it's on
the order of 24 feet on the
side. Maybe at the highest point,
you're Yeah, I'm not seeing much more than 24 feet. So I
don't expect typical development
a lot taller than that over on those parcels, but it does give you kind
of an idea of what to expect for future development.
Thanks, Brandon. Appreciate that. All right, thank you. Thank you very much. I don't
think there's any other questions, and glad to have it on our radar. Okay,
appreciate you. Thanks, guys. Thanks very much.
All right. We've been
working on this for quite a long time. It's item 1D.
I know Brad started this months ago,
and Ben's trying to get a little broader picture,
but just to show both the residents
and the council the workload that we deal with on a daily
basis, I think, here in City Hall, this is a a
little bit of a higher-level view of some of the bigger projects.
And we'll, uh, Mayor, we talked about keeping people's mental health
good. Are you sure this is a good idea? I don't know.
It's, it's never good when you're looking at me. I don't, I don't know.
I have that effect on people. But Mayor and Council, thank you
so much for the opportunity to visit with you a little bit.
And, uh, it's important to note, especially for the public,
that There's really 3
main things that the city gets involved in. It gets involved
in day-to-day operations, and that's not included on this
list. So there's a lot of things that we do on a day-to-day basis to
make sure that people have high-quality water and that that water is processed properly afterwards
and that they have parks. And, and so there's work that we do day in
and day out to make the high quality of life that we have for the
residents. Possible here in Eagle Mountain City.
Then of course there's emergency response, and that happens all the time as
well. I know you get texts from me in the middle of the night,
hey, this lift station went down, or this water tank
is having an issue, or this well's having a problem, or whatnot. So that's not
part of this either. Really what we're talking about today is our
projects that we have, and I want to give maybe a little
bit of definition to that. We have what we would call capital projects,
and that's something that would be capitalized at the end, that there would be a
technical asset at the end, like a water tank. You've got a tank,
here is a project. It starts off with trying
to figure out the funding, trying to come up with the initial design,
do land acquisitions, going out to bid. We have all sorts of
processes that we are required to follow, set by code,
set by you, the council. council so that we can make sure that we're
doing things properly and we're doing it in accordance with not only the
laws and ordinances of the City of Eagle Mountain but with the state of Utah
and federally as well. We also have projects
that are not necessarily capital projects but just projects that we would
kick off and take on that would still maybe have an asset at the end.
For example, we're looking at the observatory,
and so That's one where we're getting donations
coming in, and there's a lot of work in the background where we're getting grants
and donations and whatnot come together. There's a lot of work up front, but it's
not something that you're funding as a true full-on capital project.
There's something that I would call an initiative. So maybe we have
a really good idea come forward. Maybe we want to look into a
justice court. Maybe we want to look into solid
waste and large— getting rid of solid waste, large items and whatnot, and new
programs that we can offer to enhance the quality of life of our residents.
Those often take a lot of steps as well with many departments involved.
And so it's sort of like a project, but it's really an initiative. There's not
like an asset at the end. It's really a new program or a new offering
that might come forward. And then sometimes we just have some simply hard tasks
that are really time-intensive Maybe we're trying to do a certain land acquisition to support
the school district or something of that nature. So consequently,
I've been pulling information from various lists that we
have, trying to give you a consolidated list of
all the different projects. And even the one I sent out had some
spelling errors, which means that the form— formats are not— that
have been fixed since I've sent it out. aren't sorting exactly
perfectly. But really, we're trying to consolidate a project, a capital
project list, projects, initiatives, and even right down to the listening tour
that you have going on where you're going to various neighborhoods and residents
are asking for things. Some of those translate into a quick, quick answer,
and some of those are a major project that we're taking on or potentially
taking on. And every project out there is has
the potential to make life better for our residents. And so we
want to truly look at all of those projects
and, and, and we want to give them the due diligence needed.
But the— and sometimes the enemy of, of great is good,
because we maybe have, um, something that we really, really want
to accomplish, and then we might get diverted with other things. And so as staff,
we want to make sure that we're fully aligned with the will of the people,
which you are their elected representatives. And so we want
to make sure that we're working at your bequest and doing the things that you
would have us do. So how does that— I'm just going to go
really quickly through these first few slides and get right into the projects.
But how does the city go about doing that? Well, you know,
we have in the past, and this is more maybe for the sake of the
public, we in the past have tried to determine what our values
are as a community. And what we want to provide. And that's, you know,
a healthy and safe community. We want to have accountability and transparency.
We want to provide great services for our residents, innovation, make sure we're growing
in the right way. We want to be efficient with the dollars that
we're entrusted with, and we want sustainability. And we want to make sure
our programs can, can be sustainable and not just be one-time, one-off.
And so when we look at our values, we try to tie that back to
our strategic goals and what the council would have us work on. And we
know that you guys are going to— you're all going through a process right now
to update these. Um, where we have a new council, we're going to be making
tweaks to this. And so we want to rep— uh, respect the fact that things
do change over time, and so we need to be, uh, flexible.
But our current stated goals are really to have a diversified
economic growth. Anything that we do, we need to be able to have
the golden goose that be able to keep— have it keep going forward. So we
don't create an undue burden on our residents. We want to have robust infrastructure
that, that really can stand the test of time, unique reputational,
um, evolution. We want to, we want to have
something different when you come around Unity Pass or coming right into Eagle Mountain
itself right at the beginning, uh, from Saratoga. You want to feel the
difference, what it's like to come into Eagle Mountain and feel what Eagle Mountain's
all about. We want to be proactive and generational in our planning because we
have kids that we want to be able to retain and keep here in the
future. And so we look at schools and universities and all the different things,
job creation, to keep our kids and our grandkids near us at home.
We want to have interactive environmental stewardship. We don't
want to damage our home and what we call our
hometown. And we want to have dynamic services and enhancements. We want to make the
quality of life better for the residents that we serve. So we start with our
mission statement, and this is Eagle Mountain's mission statement. That may be tweaked in the
near future of upcoming retreats. And then from that,
we've really tried to prioritize the task that you would have us
do. And that's really done on a basis of,
first and foremost, there's nothing more important than
having a strong foundation of public safety.
That is the foundation. That is the basis. And so
that's when we look at our public safety as being the most important.
Important aspect of our community. If we can't go home and have a safe
community, have police, fire, and EMS response,
then really we have nothing that really we can offer.
But on that foundation, we build— we should have a
balanced approach to providing essential services. That's all the infrastructure
that we would provide. Economic prosperity so that people have the
ability to learn and grow and have jobs here in our community. And ultimately,
we have a great quality of life that we provide our residents. And so when
we think about all the different tasks that we could take on or all the
projects, the more that they can cross over and achieve more
than one thing, the better off we are. So if we take on a project
that not only enhances our quality of life but attracts new businesses in
as well, and our essential services that maybe this business brings,
the infrastructure can support our overall community. Community as well,
and that creates stability in property taxes that can be provided for our
public safety, that's a win across the board. And so we look at this
and we want to make sure that we're doing it and doing it in the
right way, because sometimes communities get out of balance fairly easily.
I always have used this slide since the very beginning of being a city manager.
I am absolutely confident and I have nothing but faith and trust in
the, in the city staff That we can do anything that you want.
We have talented people, great people on board that can accomplish
whatever you would have us accomplish. But we can't do everything. We can do anything,
but not everything. As soon as we try, that's when we fail, because we're spread
too thin. We are your engine. You are
the drivers. You tell us where to go. We will get you there.
That's the whole ultimate thing. We talked in one of
our last retreats about financial best practices. need to use budgeting
as a tool to establish our priorities into tangible dollars so that
projects really do move forward in a manner that you, the elected leaders, would establish.
Our, our enterprise funds should be, um, and what are enterprise
funds for the sake of the residents? An enterprise fund
is a fund that we consider to be like a business. So our water
fund supports water, and our water rates should be, uh, set and
established such that they cover the costs of running that
enterprise. Sewer for sewer and storm
drainage for storm drainage, all those different enterprise funds are treated as businesses.
Our general fund is much larger, and, and that's where we take
some of our other things like public safety out of.
I have used this quite a bit, that we can't spend our
income, we can only spend our income.
So real dollars is what we can actually plan for. In Eagle
Mountain, I have learned that there's another term called when-come,
meaning that if-come is if it translates. But let's
face it, Eagle Mountain is growing so quickly and we have things being built
on the fly. We know that they're going to come, and so it is a
matter of when some of those financial benefits will hit our residents.
And I truly believe that it's going to transform our We're on a tipping point
of where we're going as a community, and so long as we create a
financially stable environment, I believe
very firmly that Eagle Mountain is going to continue to bloom and prosper with
great jobs, great opportunities, and quality of
life like we've never had before. We don't want to spend
one-time dollars for recurring purposes. We want to create stable,
sustainable revenue streams streams. So, and we want to tie those most
stable revenue streams to our most essential services like public safety.
We want to maintain what we have rather
than replace. We got to take care of what we own. It's kind of like
changing the oil in your car. You change the oil in your car so you
don't have to replace that car, right? So we take care of what we have.
We should only dip into reserves for emergency purposes. It's better for us to
own versus rent. So we have to think about that when it comes to,
like, city facilities. And that the city is like building a house.
When we build a city, we start with the foundation and we work our way
up. And many years I've spent in another city
where all we wanted to talk about was what color
the house was going to be, or what kind of curtains we were going to
put up, or how large the kitchen was. But there was nothing more important than
starting with the foundation and making sure it was stable and strong. Thank you.
And it had good compaction, and then we start building the walls and the roof
to make sure it's not getting wet, and we do things in the right order,
and everything else will take care of itself. When it comes to revenue,
there's really three main revenues for a city: it's our property taxes,
our sales taxes, and the fees that we charge. And so we have
to have balanced and stable revenue streams. And if
we rely on on things that are changing from
time to time, like sales tax, then we follow the winds of
the market and not necessarily the stability that comes from having
diversification of our revenues. With that said,
I use the analogy of a house. What is the foundation
of our house? It really is public safety. From that,
we have to have our infrastructure, which is our public works,
and that builds our essential services. From there, we can have our economic
prosperity. And when it's all said and done, that enhances the quality of life with
the color of the curtains or the color of the house or whatnot.
And so all of these tasks, we really need to start looking at
them, all these potential projects that we're taking on, we need to look at them
through the prism of what is the most important.
And oftentimes we have to deal with the urgent. Sometimes the urgent is,
hey, there's a water leak, a water main blew, and we got to go take
care of it. But the important is maybe we need
to be checking every single one of our sewer manholes on a regular
basis, on a routine, to make sure that we're not— and we're cleaning out our
sewer mains so we don't have a backup. You know what I mean? That's regular
maintaining maintenance. That's important. The urgent is
when it gets blocked. And of course, then we also have things that are not
important nor urgent, and those are things that can waste or be time wasters.
Okay. And so when we start looking at that and we want to try
to become more effective as an organization, we also have to recognize that
we have certain bandwidth and we also have certain growth that we
need to do. And so I'm trying to really work hard to build the future
of our city. We're about a third the size of staff
as comparable cities of our size. And so I recognize that staff
that I do have today are the leaders of the future as we continue to
build more and bring more frontline employees on.
And so we're doing things like a leadership training
program right now where we have more than 55 members of our
staff, either current or future leaders who want to be future leaders,
learning about management principles and leadership principles and how they
can better grow and lead their organizations going forward.
We can't all do it. We've the bottleneck if we don't
rely and trust on others and let them grow in their roles.
So we're looking at organizational alignment and policy maturity so we can go from
a crawl to a walk to a fly. And I— and of course I had
to put the fly in there because if there's anything I like, it's aviation.
So what's— what are the major projects? I sent a spreadsheet out to
the council, and that spreadsheet is actively being worked on by
our functional area directors and their department heads right now.
And so it is changing on the fly. But I just wanted
to review for you and for the public some of those major things that we
have going on. And I want to talk about how best
and what your direction would be on how we could prioritize those.
Because some things, it's going to be challenging to prioritize because
they're already active. We're already moving forward. So those have been approved in the
past. Some have the opportunity for
us to be evaluated on whether we should take them on or not. So I
just broke down some of the top ones, not all of them, but some of
the top, uh, projects that our current, um, city staff is wor— working
on to make enhancements right now to enhance the quality of
life of our residents. And these are not ranked, these are just thrown on the
board, and we are looking to our elected leaders and the public in general to
help us rank some of these. But Um, I've broken them down into logical areas.
Public Works, Transportation— that's probably the hottest item on anyone's
radar, is that we want to get in and out of our community more,
uh, quickly, but we want to do so in a manner that's safe for
our residents. And so we're currently doing a pedestrian safety study
and looking at speed tables, pedestrian safety enhancements,
and the council has authorized and wants us to move forward
to ensure that we're putting in— it's not necessarily speed tables, but we're putting in
all of those improvements that are going to enhance the safety of each elementary
school, each middle school, high school in our community. Silver Lake,
Woodhaven, free right turn lanes. That's going to get people out of those neighborhoods
more quickly. Silver Lake community traffic
improvements. We're looking at the connection to the high school, and if we're going to
make that connection, what improvements do we need to make to intersections going north to
make that so that those— so that
added traffic doesn't negatively impact the elementary schools in that area.
So we're looking at removing roundabouts and putting new traffic signals in,
having better crosswalks and better pedestrian crossings.
Branches Parkway median removal. David's working on removing
those medians. There's really 2 projects that are going on, the High
Tea Campus Drive in Ranches That's going to make it flow better as you're
going north and you're over by the turnoff to the chamber or
the city offices to the north. And also to the
medians and making that wider so that we can have 6
lanes and then a center turn lane on that
Ranches connection between our 2 major arteries.
Trailhead, that's the intersection right outside here, and being
able to put a light in at Trailhead and
Pony Express. We're working on expanding and
widening Pony Express going south of Eagle Mountain Boulevard. Right now
it's 2-lane. That's going to be 4-lane. This is something that's going to be funded
directly by QTS. And so
we really appreciate the data centers and their contributions to trying to
enhance the quality and flow of traffic in that area.
But that's really, um, widening it, um, to 5
lanes all the way south to, uh, Pole Canyon Road intersection,
and then putting in, uh, the new intersection improvements there at
Pole Canyon Road. And then of course we're updating our Transportation Master
Plan, Impact Fee Facility Plan, and IFA for anything transportation.
That's actually on the agenda tonight as far as the Transportation Master Plan is concerned.
These are not all the transportation projects. These are just of the ones that
we wanted to highlight. We would like your input on how to prioritize them,
um, as we move forward— these and the ones that haven't been listed.
Um, Public Works and Water. We know that water is the next most
essential asset in our community, and making sure that we have water,
uh, resources for our community to continue to, to blossom, to grow,
so our kids and grandkids can live near us. Um,
And not just in my basement like I have mine. So Central
Utah Water line and a secondary water line is is being planned
right now in the new booster station, City Center. We have a new water
tank going in on the side of the mountain over here. The council just took
a tour of that on the hillside there. We have repairs
to Well Two going on, enhancements to Well Five.
Well Seven is under design right now. That's by
Unity Pass, and that's where a new well house will be built.
Well 8 is about to come online, and Well 9 is about to be drilled.
So we have new water resources that we are putting in,
and each one of these wells takes several years to develop and
several million dollars per well to have them come online.
We have the new Bell Street booster station that's over by the, the new middle
school, the Butterfield PRV valve Creating pressure zones.
White Hills Booster Station. Oops, I got
White Hills spelled 2 different ways. But White Hills Well upgrade that
needs to take place. Culinary Water Master Plan, IFFP and IFA.
And allocation-based tiered water rates analysis. That's something
the council's had us work on where we are looking
at how much water had been dedicated, not based on the property size,
and so we're creating undue restrictions based on arbitrary numbers.
But we are looking at how much water is dedicated to each lot,
and that we're charging the appropriate amount based
on what someone has brought in for the benefit of their home. And so,
and creating more realistic, so if people are overusing water, they're charged
appropriately, and if people are within their water that they've delegated,
Great. And so we're doing all sorts of things to try to enhance our overall
water usage. When it comes to things like
wastewater, we're working right now on the wastewater treatment plant.
This is a 6 million gallons per
day enhancement to our sewer treatment system.
This is— there's some major hurdles that we're working to
overcome there. Of course, we're going through the bonding process right now.
Getting rated for this major project. But we also are working
with the state to get our permit in order to put this project
forward. We're trying to get a reuse permit so we can reuse that water and,
and, and make precious use of every drip every time over and over again.
And effluent planning— we want to make sure that as we're taking water out
of that sewer treatment plant that we're doing it in an appropriate way and we're
getting proper return flows but not doing it in a manner that could create
environmental risk or hazards. Part of that
is we're enhancing our current treatment plant with a tertiary treatment phase 2.
We also recognize that as we put new sewer infrastructure
in, we have to have newer sewer trunk line— sewer trunk lines to bring that
sewer influent into the sewer treatment plant. So we have an
east sewer trunk line underway. Like I mentioned,
the effluent disposal upgrades Um, wastewater master plan,
IFA, IFFP. Um, we're cleaning up our boundary with
TSSD for the north area of our community right now. And then we have
things like, uh, that pop up, like the Scenic Mountain neighborhood that
wants us to look at their lift station and should we bring that in as
a city asset or not. And so we're trying to do evaluations on that,
and we're trying to get data from them.
And also other projects to support specific neighborhoods like the Lone Tree,
Forest Main, um, and etc. There's, there's many more projects that
aren't listed. These are just some of the wastewater things that we're doing today.
We also recognize that we have parks and we want to make those parks,
um, accessible and usable and raise the quality of life for our residents.
And so some of the things that the, the community may not be aware
of that's going on— a lot of people have asked, what are those poles going
up at Cory Wright Park when they're in the middle of nowhere? And they're— what's
going on those poles? Those are actually festival field lighting, um, to enhance
and, and light that area so we can do more events at night. We're putting
a new parking lot out at Quarry Ride Park. Um, we're probably going to
be putting on those light poles, um, added, uh, Wi-Fi so we
can have better, um, uh, utilization out of the park as well.
Um, I mentioned earlier at the very beginning the observatory. That's a project that
started from the data centers for Meta. They made a donation And that
has led to getting a grant from Utah
County and from getting donations from UVU and some of their major
donors and more money coming in from Meta. And we finally have a fully
funded project to bring in an observatory into our community because of the dark
skies that we enjoy and tying that in with educational programming with
our school district and with our university.
As we've been doing our neighborhood tours, questions came up like, When's the Sweetwater Community
Park going to be completed? And so we've been answering those questions and
working with developers. Nolan Park improvements, phase 1, Nolan Park splash
pad. That the difference between Nolan Park splash pad and the splash
pad at Quarry Ride Park is one recirculates the water, and so it's
a good use of the water, but it's very expensive to do that.
And the other one's just the water goes right down the drain, and so it's
a poor use of water. And so if we're going to make Nolan Park splash
pad truly usable, we need to make it so that it's sustainable as well.
And then of course our Parks and Trails Master Plan and making sure that all
of our parks connect with trails and, and all the enhancements and making sure
our trails are properly managed so that we're not incompatible
uses and having e-bikes that are impacting walkers and
things like that. So there's a lot of code changes and restrictions and whatnot.
And of course open space management. We have a lot of open spaces that we
need to maintain, and the council's trying to evaluate what projects makes
most sense to enhance our open spaces and where open space
might be able to go back to ownership by the, um, by the neighboring parcels.
Um, with facilities, we know that our staff is a third of
the size of other city staffs, and yet we're, um,
we're basically, um, extremely tight in the office space
that we have, and we're leasing office space and paying for rental costs right
now. And so we're trying to create a temporary office space plan on how we
can continue to enhance and add more staff so that we can support the residents
that are coming to our community. But we're doing it in such a way that,
that, um, makes financial sense, that we own an asset at
the end, uh, because ultimately our long-term goal is to get our staff consolidated
in a new city hall, have a new downtown, a third space, uh,
where we can bring our community together. And so we're working
on new city hall downtown planning. We also have things like
our public works yard improvements, our north service area planning.
Um, there's desire for recreational venues. You know, all of those are enhancements
to the quality of life and, and their ability to serve the residents of Eagle
Mountain City. When it comes to things like public safety,
another high priority for us is to recognize that that public safety
not only is our most essential service, but we have to do it in an
affordable way. And so, um, as we are a
taxing entity with Unified Fire through
UFSA, and as our city's financial base is growing,
we have to step away from that and become a contract
city like some of our other participating cities so that
we can responsibly do that and not put an overarching and or high
level of tax on our residents. And so we are working on a
conversion to step away from UFSA but maintain the
great relationship and the great services that UFA provides. There's no doubt that they're the
top, top-notch, high quality, and we, we love having the work
that UFA does for us. But let's do it in such a way that as
we add more data centers and more taxable value, that we're not creating
an undue burden on our residents. We also have to look at
our long-term public safety needs. Does that mean remodeling
this building? Does it mean including it in City Hall in
the future? And what does the future of law enforcement mean?
Right now, all of our law enforcement is through
an outsourced agreement with Utah County. And what we don't recognize,
and one of the things that they provide, is all of their evidence
storage, all of their training facilities, all of their overhead,
all of their, um, um,
uh, you know, exercise facilities, anything that they have, their sally ports,
their maintenance, their fleet, all that type of thing, all takes place in Spanish
Fork. If we were to do that in-house, we would have to take on those
costs and those burdens. And so we have to figure that out. And we also
have to work, work with the county on a, on a very, on a wise
transition plan, uh, and do so in harmony that it's beneficial
for all parties involved, but most importantly for the residents we all serve.
Um, our public safety master plan is part of that with our IFFP and
IFA there. And then we have new things pop up like the Best Friends Animal
Society proposal that just came in last meeting. You know, it's another idea,
another great program. Um, how does that fit into the overall view?
As far as community development, I'm only— I'm not even going to hit all the
departments, but As far as community development, I know that they're working very hard on
water-wise landscaping codes. They just spent time with our
public works department and some of our council learning about water-wise landscaping
from Utah State University and how we can
make the best use of our water moving forward.
Trying to track our MDAs to
make sure that we all the requirements of developers are really being put in by
developers and having tools in place to build and help us. Our general plan—
so we have the guiding document of where we're going and where would you want
us to be as a community. Our rodeo grounds planning,
consideration of new plans for plan review software,
various code updates from the senior housing to the mining overlay to
seasonal signs to artificial turf. I mean, there's all sorts of things
that are on there. Their to-do plate. And then new things that come up like
the Sage Valley neighborhood sign that we want to be able
to support not only for Sage Valley but all for all of our communities as
they are trying to have greater and greater community pride.
As far as community services, or a lot of people call that leisure services,
that really gets into the setup of our community services board,
how they're going to be usually utilizing the wrap text. dollars and how they're going
to be enhancing the quality of life for our parks and trails and whatnot.
Great things are taking place with Eagle Mountain 30 and USA 250
events this year, but we're trying to take in-house our soccer
programs. We're trying to look at our CITLA trails and make
sure that we have legitimate use of the trails in our community
that people are enjoying but don't necessarily have all
the rights to as far as CITLA is concerned or other private property.
Steve tonight talked about the Healthy Utah Initiative. We've talked
about bringing other amenities to our community like skate rinks and things like that
because there's economic opportunities and partnerships with Utah County and
the private sector that might be able to benefit our community.
And just some of the things on administration, everything from Justice Court
to bulk garbage analysis to customer advocacy department
and setting that up to turn to make sure that we're basically helping
the customer from the moment they call all the way through until they get resolution
of their issue. We're trying to educate the public with
Citizens Academy and making sure that they're aware of all the things that are going
on that makes life better, worth living here in Eagle Mountain City.
I've talked about the leadership development program.
Intergovernmental relations and advocacy. You know, we get impacted by the state
all the time with league activities and and legislative
changes. And so there's a lot of work that goes into that.
Various land acquisitions and disposal. I didn't even touch water when it comes
to all the water rights and all that type of thing.
Website upgrades, project enhancements, project management software rollout so
we can track all of this work. So ultimately, that's really the
end of the presentation. Where I'd like to go right
now is to get the council's direction on one thing,
um, from this list that is going to continue to evolve and continue
to flesh out. We can have the council prioritize
that list first and then have the staff take a crack at it.
We could have the staff and the council concurrently rank it.
But what I would recommend is that you would allow the staff to
rank the project by department. Now, not 1 to 200
of the projects that we have, but But, you know, 1 to 15 in
the water department, 1 to 15 in the sewer department or whatnot.
You allow the staff to rank those out based on what they consider the highest
priority in their critical path items and whatnot, and then send that to you so
that you can then review that, make tweaks as you see fit, and then set
the final word. These are our priorities moving forward.
Because your insights might push projects up or down on that list.
But having the insight of knowing what staff's recommending first is probably the best place
to start. And so I'll leave it to you. You tell us.
We work for you. We work at the pleasure. You tell us what you'd like
us to do and how you want us to do it. There was one other
thing that I was going to mention too, is that Mr. Magnus is here as
well that helped with that prioritization. He's worked— he works
on our legislative priority list. That's a whole other list that got moved into
here. So we can have him join in on any of this that you
guys give direction on, but is that the
direction you want? Just have staff go ahead and rank this and then we kind
of weigh in on some of those? And one of this, you know, like you've
heard me say it before, it's like, well, what don't you want us to do
if we're going to add this? Because it just gets to be a— Why are
you looking at me? I'm just looking down at general diaspora.
Every idea is a good idea. We love them all. But it's, you know,
I mean, you kind of get— this was literally the top 4 or
5, and there's hundreds of things. So just an idea of the workload that
we're dealing with. And, uh, you know, we want to make sure that we're
doing things but not also chasing rabbits, is what we talked about too. So,
um, direction, insight?
I'm comfortable with the staff providing their recommendations. They're the
ones that are closest to the source, and I'd love to hear their insights for
sure. Yeah, I would agree
with that. And then maybe the council could provide some feedback to,
you know, we're probably going to be close where maybe they
rank it number 1, but residents would rank it number 2.
So some— that might be a good starting point to rank
it and bring it back to the council, and then we can tweak it,
reorder a little bit. Great. I'm sorry,
Mayor. I was just— and then there's some things that might not show up on
the list, but we know are deeper down there that you might want to move
up into that top 15, right? That's, that's kind of the idea as well,
that we can move things forward. Go ahead. Um, I was just going to say,
I think having the information, like if we're at like a critical
state, like we're at capacity for a
wastewater treatment plant or something like that, I think that needs
to be conveyed to us too as part of that prioritization.
So it's not just arbitrarily us choosing, but we're
given that additional information. You know, that, that's a— you make a really good point.
And I just look at just today alone. Today,
um, we're not only looking at, you know, the impacts
of a property tax increase on our finance department, but we're trying to,
to do bonding for the new sewer treatment plant. We're trying to bring in
the Smiths and the Kroger. We're trying to complete an audit.
We're trying to start another audit. And answer community questions
all at the same time. And so I think I look at
the stress level for the finance
department and it may not be high all the time, but this is probably one
of your higher weeks. You know, and I think that is probably
true for every department, right? There's times when the water system,
you know, Mac is just dying because all
the water system's falling apart all of a sudden. time. And so every
department goes through their pain.
First, Ben, thanks for providing this. And it's not even an
exhaustive list, what you sent out in the email. I think that's really helpful.
I think there are some things even that you put on what you kind of
brought here that I think ought to disappear, if I'm being completely frank.
Sure. And probably because I
And maybe the council will feel differently. OK, well, some came from
a previous council that may not be relevant anymore. Well, I'll just give a
very specific example, like the ice skating rink. I think we pursued that to a
degree and to a level, and in my opinion, there's no sense chasing that.
Maybe there is among the rest of the council members, but so I like
the idea of the staff evaluating it, saying, look, these are the things that we
think are most important, the most— the top 15. We have the 200 to
look at. look at and to look at it and say, look, you guys missed
this, or you missed this, or you missed this. We think that this should have
a higher priority. And then we can have that, that discussion about
those things. And if there's anything I want to stress,
we're all one team. Oh yeah, for sure. 100%. We support you,
and we feel like we're in— we just want to be aligned. But I,
but I also think there's wisdom in, in allowing us to give some input so
we're not chasing those rabbits. The ice skating rink at least is one, in my
opinion. I don't think that we should be exhausting or using
resources to chase that. I think that there's a fairly definitive answer that
today's not the right time to pursue that. Now that's just my opinion, but at
least if we know that that's something that's still on your radar that you guys
are concerned about and that you've kind of felt some direction
from the council or the mayor, we ought to have that discussion and say let's
dismiss that and get it off your lives. Let me answer that one for just
a second. So the only reason that came up is because there was some donations
that paid— almost paid for it, just like the observatory.
As those donations and contributions kind of
aren't fleshed out, we're not working on it. Yeah, and I'm not saying it was
inappropriate to chase it. I think it was good to pursue it to gain an
understanding. But my understanding is at this point in time, that's kind of
a worthless chase, isn't it? Only if it's funded by outside sources.
And that's where we're at. So if it's funded, great. If it's not, then— Set
it aside and forget about it. Yeah. Well, and, and, you know, it's maybe
just the timing's not right. As soon as we get some of these needs,
these foundational needs like sewer and water worked out, then we might
have time for things like recreational improvements.
I would say that I think it would be helpful for us to understand time.
Man-hours would be important to be added to this. I think it would be good
for us to Which funding
source would be utilized for this?
And then I think understanding time, because I'm
looking through this. I have been doing a lot of exercises with AI lately from
these types of things. So I love having this information here to just go and
show me the workload. Who's carrying it? It's pretty interesting.
Exercise to find out how many projects
have been placed on one individual person, which is why they're not getting done.
I mean, that's the reality of it. There's only a certain amount of time in
a day. And I think understanding the amount of time
that it's going to be to take that, what the cost of it's going to
be, how it's going to be funded, should be things that we should be prioritizing
that information. So if it's, you know, if it's something that's going to take 3
years, it's probably not the highest priority for them to be spending every minute of
every day on. But I think we're probably out of the loop as to what
the timeframe for each of these things are. And when we make an ask,
it would be good to say, okay, if you're okay with that, that's 30 man-hours.
We don't have a person to do 30 man-hours. So which
project would you like them to put on pause to accomplish that? And I think
that gives us better idea of what is important, what's not
important. Maybe to Brett's point, maybe some of these things that we have people chasing
after are really just dead ends and we need to get rid of them.
I think that's important too. A conversation we had is maybe if it's 30 man-hours
and we can see that we can't get to everything, maybe we need another guy.
'Cause we can see the man-hours that we're not covering, right?
Anything else? Any input?
I think you— so— Can you maybe get the staff to
prioritize these, give us a little bit of a guess on man hours? And they
will flesh it out. I just took lists and consolidated them. Some of the departments
aren't fully fleshed out, so there's gonna be other things added to this. I guarantee
it's gonna go from 200 to 300. Every day new projects come up.
Yep. Okay, thank you. Perfect, thanks. I think
that's good insight on the workload, and I've been talking about
it a lot privately with each of you, that is, Man, we're busy and we
all know during the budget process we need staff and there's a lot to do.
But while you get back up here, the next items,
any updates? But I think that kind of covered it. Did you have anything on
top of that outside? I think that covered it pretty well. Okay,
then we'll go ahead and review some of the agenda,
specifically the closed session, or sorry, not closed session, the consent
agenda. There's some appointments
for the Youth Council. We've got the list Craig's been working on. I've seen over
here, so you guys have seen the entire Youth Council list, correct?
Any questions?
Miss Eagle Mountain is going to do an introduction. We have
some minutes. July 21st,
we're good. Site plan with
the chapel and recreation building. We've We've seen this quite a bit recently.
Is there any other questions on that one?
And then an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City approving the same
site plan, the chapel and recreation building. The development
agreement. Yeah, development agreement, sorry.
Nothing on that one? Okay. Then a couple scheduled
items. If we— we do have a couple minutes if we can ask some questions.
Now, I don't know if Kiara's here.
Oh, this is public hearing. Oh yeah, yeah, that's just a public hearing only.
And then, uh, on the, uh, CBDG— CDBG
action plan. So we'll take care of that. And then the rezoning
of Scenic Mountain, which is just from a traditional, uh, zone to
our current zoning. Um, any questions on that one? Any comments?
need any information provided. Mayor,
Evan had his hand up just for a second. Oh, okay.
Probably back on the public hearing. I'm just guessing.
Yeah, so we, um, just back on the CDBG public hearing, um,
we discovered that there was an issue with that agenda item. It was not
meant to be just a public hearing. There's supposed to be action taken.
Um, we're supposed to submit are planned to HUD
by August 18th. And as
far as we understand, there's not really any way— August 14th. August 14th.
Sorry. Yes, August 18th is the next council meeting. August 14th.
So we're kind of in a little bit of a tough spot because as
far as I understand, there's not anything we can do to change the agenda tonight.
So we wanted to just ask if there's any possibility
we could do some sort of a special council meeting next week if we
can get a quorum together just to approve the plan.
It'd be a very short agenda obviously, but that's kind of the last thing that
we're left with. Remote too? That's remote,
that's easy. Is that,
when are you thinking, Evan? What kind of timeline are
you seeing? Whenever we can get a quorum together really.
We just need 3 people to sign off on
it. So whatever is available for 3 people. Tuesday, Wednesday. It could be
virtual morning or lunch. Right, they could appear virtually.
It doesn't have to be after work hours.
Yeah. I'll make myself available. I mean,
I can— Wednesday is— I'm hearing a Wednesday.
That would be the 12th. Monday and Tuesday at noon are good for
me. Monday and Tuesday midday. Is Wednesday afternoon good as well?
Wednesday's better for me. Like 5,
6 o'clock Wednesday? Yeah, I can do Wednesday afternoon. I can do
that on Wednesday as well. So it sounds like we'd at least
have a quorum on Wednesday at 5, 6. I can't
do it in that late. Mine's earlier. So if somebody else wants to do it.
Damon starts football. Wednesday. What's the latest you can go for? I could do
earlier. I have like noon. Noon? I'm fine. Which day?
Wednesday. Yeah, I could do that,
especially if it's virtual. I can't do Wednesday noon,
but that's okay. What about Tuesday? I think it's important that,
'cause it's all of us making a decision about where we're spending those
dollars. So is there a time that we can find for everyone?
Or Tuesday? How about everyone's Tuesday?
Do we have Tuesday middle of day or Tuesday late afternoon?
What are we at? Tuesday I'm good 12 to 2. Okay, anyone else?
12 to 2 on Tuesday.
Okay, what about Thursday? Monday,
hang on, Monday? Monday through Monday afternoon. I can do Monday.
Monday after 3. Perfect. Okay,
Monday after 3? All right, let's do it. There you have it.
So Monday the 10th at
3:30. Will you send an invite
please? Just so I can get it on my calendar and block it off.
It'll be a virtual 3:30 Monday.
Uh, I suppose Kiara or anybody that needs to be there could
also be there. You're gonna handle this? Yeah, Kiara and Elizabeth will help with that.
Okay, let's, let's put it on for Monday the 10th,
3:30. Send an— Lacey, would you send an invite
to council for that? And then we'll— So does the public hearing still happen
today then? Yes, it still needs to happen today. Yeah, I appreciate
you making that time, accommodating. Thanks. Okay,
thank you. All right, we already talked about the Scenic Mountain,
then, uh, the TMP, that's the Transportation Master Plan,
IFF Do you guys have questions specifically on
that that we could go over now before we? I've got questions on that,
but I think it's probably better with the larger presentation that's happening anyway.
I think it's a. I don't know if we want to dive into that now.
It's almost six o'clock. Okay, so we'll
wait on that one. I am going to try something a little bit different because
it's we have just a second. The legislative priority list
item seventeen. A lot of times we keep. Mr. Magnus here till wee
hours of the night, and if there's anything— if we need to make
any motions, we'll have to do that later. But at least we could— if there's
not, we could cut him loose a lot earlier than we normally do,
although I know he loves staying with us.
So maybe we can knock out some legislative priority, anything on
the list, and then— So we haven't knocked anything
on the list. It's pretty short these days. days. I still owe you the list
for the state legislative. What I've been doing is going through all the minutes
and agendas for all the interim committees. I finished that
today, so I'll send that out so you know what's been happening at
the state level, plus the other list that we talked about. I'll get those out
and start meeting with you guys. Right now it looks like water is going to
take top priority just because of the drought, and then followed by
housing. Thank you. So those are the 2 areas that I'm seeing there's a lot
of discussion and movement on. So that's at the
state level. Internally with the city, we're still working
on things. I'm still trying to get the people with the poured
concrete fences to return my phone calls.
So as soon as I get that done, I'll get ahold of you,
Councilmember Woods, and start working on the design.
So I have one item. I had a builder approach me wondering
if we can get more ladder signs. And I know, Councilmember Clark,
I think there was something you were pursuing with wanting more
ladder signs. I don't know what even the process is for that. This is me
wearing a different hat. So, um, I know
that the chamber has submitted something with Mr. Salazar and
has CC'd you on it and Abby Ivory,
and I will let you guys communicate with the chamber
staff instead of me about the signs, if that helps. What would the process be?
So if, if a builder is asking for more— So I'll talk to you about
code. Our code right now limits the number, and it requires that the
map has to get brought back to the city council
for approval every single time something changes. If there were going to be additional
sign locations added, it would need to be either the city council
approves it every single time, or there's a code change made to change it so
that maybe city engineer and economic development make decisions
about where new locations can go. Okay, 'cause the issue we're running
into is on the south side of Cedar Valley, we're having new construction
happen and newer subdivisions going in down there and probably
inadequate signage that didn't contemplate the new— well,
new growth's happening down there, but our current signage is probably insufficient.
Hannah is ready to talk to you all about it. So if you want to
reach out to her tomorrow, she'll be able to fill you in all the details.
So I've heard— I don't know that all council members are in
favor of increasing those ladder signs. However, when we're talking about
the expansion toward the south end, does that change?
For me, I think that if we're going to consider that, that we
ought to have a work session discussion about it and a presentation about where those
areas I would be in favor
of that. So I think rather than— what I'm gathering, rather than
a legislative priority or on John's radar, it's more something that we've got to talk
about as a discussion item or something. Yeah, I think so, because I think part
of that discussion has to be if we're creating this because developers are asking for
it, there probably needs to be a clock on these signs so that they aren't
there forevermore. Because there's a lot
that are already in our city, and once the building stops, then what? Well,
I think a heat map so that we kind of look at it and say,
look, we have this type of density in this area, and so that
there's some, at least some equalization of that citywide. And I think that may
be what you're referencing, Craig. That's why I just think it's a broader
discussion, because if it's, if it's just can we raise the number to this number,
my answer is going to be no. If there's data to support it
that says, look, in this area we have a saturation rate of
X, but in this area we don't have any signs at all and there's a
need to approve some in this area, that's, that's a discussion I'm willing to
have. So I think some of those new areas would be the south of the
city, but also Firefly. I don't remember if there's any signs out there. Look,
we're growing all over the place, and so I think we ought to
be willing to have the conversation, but I think it needs to be data-driven.
I didn't have anything to add to Craig. I think that's a good idea.
The one thing that I had brought to Evan was regarding trailers.
I'm wondering if we could bring that back in a work session regarding multiple
parking, multiple trailers.
I'm going to say on like mid-range lots,
half acre to acre, where people are stacking 3,
4, 5 RV trailers, it's obviously a business.
And I'm just wondering if— I know that's come up to the council before,
but I think we haven't landed on a solution and we need to find a
solution, whether that's better screening. Maybe one trailer
can be publicly visible, but the other 5 need to be screened
away from view. We've got that going on, I think, about 4
or 5 properties in my own neighborhood. And I would imagine it's probably happening throughout
the city in other areas.
So what I'm hearing, Lacey, is if you'll add for upcoming items,
uh, the trailer parking code that I know we've worked on in the past— is
that— was it trailer? Just for discussion? Yeah, for discussion items. And then,
uh, in work session, and then the, uh, potential locations
for ladder signs, we can get Hannah to Do a presentation or
let us know where we're deficient on that,
with the help of staff if that's needed. If is the
presentation from the chamber sufficient on that?
Is that probably? Is that I can make sure that the staff
knows that they need to prepare a heat map and some of the things that
you guys have asked for. At the chamber is what she means.
You mean the staff at the chamber? Yes. Okay, I just wanted to clarify.
I'll convey that message to them. Yeah, I just didn't
want our staff saying, okay, there's 205 on my list now.
So is there anything else, legislative priorities, that we need to put on John's radar
for today? Nothing?
Okay, then we do have a couple closed session items
that we could take care of. I know Craig's ready to make a motion.
I move the City Council adjourn to a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
subsection 1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wood,
right? Uh, start the vote with Councilmember Hughes. Yes. Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Clark.
Yes. Okay, at 6:06, we'll adjourn to closed session.
In the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
Okay, we'll go ahead and call this policy session
to order at 7:05. And, uh,
as we get started, we've asked our Miss Eagle Mountain 2026, Trias,
to lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Please join me in the Pledge of Allegiance. I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United States of America,
And to the republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice
for all.
All right. Mr.
Reeves, do we have any public information items? We do.
Yes. One more, Mayor. Our Youth City Council is having
their Summer Splash event tomorrow,
Wednesday, August 5th, from 2 to 4 PM at Corey
Ride Memorial Park. If you want a chance to dunk your favorite
council member, you can certainly come out and do that in our dunk tank.
Truth in Taxation public hearing will be Thursday, August 6th,
at 6 PM here at City Hall in the chambers. Farmers Market is every
Saturday from 9 to 1 PM through October 10th at Glory
Ride Park. And then there's another event, Ties and Tiaras, this Saturday—
or on Saturday, August 15th at 7 PM at the Overland
Barn. If you guys have never
seen Councilmember Wright dress up in a— I don't even know the old rockers—
a wig that looks like Jimi Hendrix.
Yeah, I look good with hair, let me tell you that.
Come to the Youth Council. I was wondering why they were all here to support
Duncan Councilmember Wright, right? All right, moving right along.
We do have our entire Youth Council here, most of them,
and they will get sworn in today. So how this is going to work,
we're gonna make a couple motions, then we have to vote. No telling where
that's going to go. And then we'll call all of you forward, do the mayor
first, right, Lacey? Or did you want to do them all together? Mayor first and
then the rest of the council together. Okay, so that's the way we'll do
this. And, uh, with that, I think Councilmember Whiting's
got a motion. It's my honor to move to approve
KJ Call as the Youth Council Mayor until the— for a
term until the next Youth Council election in 2027.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Whiting,
a second by Councilmember Wood. We'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood? Yes.
And Councilmember Herwish? Yes.
Okay. The Youth Council? And it's also
my honor to move to approve the following individuals as Youth Council
committee members: Sophia Anderson, Eliza Byrd,
Elena Call, Cora Davis, Jordan Deinhart,
Hinckley Franco, Kali Franco, Raina Howell,
Carly Jackson, Lexi Jackson, Ryker Jackson, Xander Jackson,
Lily Messerly, Sarah Ortega, Abigail Pace,
Darcy Washburn, and Lucy Washburn, and, uh, for a term
until the next Youth Council election in 2027. Second.
Okay, we have a motion again by Council Member Whiting, a second by Council Member
Wood. Council Member Wright? Yes. Council Member Whiting? Yes. Council Member
Wood? Yes. Council Member Huish? Yes. Councilmember Clark? Yes.
Perfect. We'll bring the mayor up and, uh,
Lacey will go over there and we're going to come down and so we can
congratulate everybody at the end. So when they're done, all the Youth Council
that was, uh, okay. Oh yeah, everybody come up then.
That's, that's why I was asking. So everybody at the same time.
Yeah, and we're gonna come— no, let's do the picture from
up here. Yeah, we'll stay up here and we'll do a picture after.
All right, we're gonna have you guys just squeeze in a little bit right here.
Our photographer for the city is gonna get right
there. We're gonna get a nice little picture, so get close together.
Not you.
Lacey, do they need to sign the— They have their oaths of office.
They can sign them and take them home.
Okay, thanks guys. Appreciate your willingness to serve.
Okay, we've got another cool recognition that
we'll get another picture for here in just a second, but it's our honor
to introduce our 2026 Miss Eagle Mountain.
We'll have you guys come up and state
your names, tell us a little something you think we need to hear, and then
do the same thing. We'll turn around up here and get a picture.
Go ahead to the microphone up here.
Good evening, my name is Emmeline Smith and I'm honored to serve this year as
Miss Teen Eagle Mountain's first runner-up. Through my community service initiative,
Life Lifesavers in Training, I plan to teach kids, teens, and adults
basic first aid and emergency response skills so they can feel more prepared
when in an emergency. I'm excited to represent
Eagle Mountain this year through this community that has already given
me so much. Thank you.
Good evening, City Council members. My name is Brighton Hawes, and I'm honored to
serve as Eagle Mountain's teen. My CSI is
called Generation for Wildlife, and it's about educating the youth on the
importance of preservation and conservation of wildlife.
I'm excited for this year, and I think it's going to be great. Thank you.
Mine's a little longer, so I'm going to warn you. Good evening, Mayor and City
Council. For those of you who don't know me, my name is Treea Smith,
and I'm so, so honored to be able to be crowned Miss
Eagle Mountain of 20— for 2026. This was my 5th year competing for the
title, so standing here today truly is such a dream come true, and I
could not be more grateful for the opportunity that has fallen into my hands this
year. This year, my community service initiative is Red,
White, and Your Rights, which focuses on civic engagement among
young voters. As many of you know, the voter turnout in Eagle Mountain
is severely low. So my goal this year is
to help young adults register to vote,
know how candidates get on a ballot, and also
know how to participate in the voting process.
Local government impacts our everyday life, and I believe being informed in
voting is one of the most meaningful ways that we can truly make a difference.
We've already had so much fun and an incredible start to the year.
We have been going to events, working alongside
Don and Dave, and getting to meet so many amazing families, local businesses,
and community members. Every event has reminded me why I love Eagle
Mountain so much. Thank you guys for allowing me the opportunity
to serve this amazing city, and I look forward to working alongside of each
of you this year and to represent Eagle Mountain with pride.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you.
So I'm going to have you guys turn around. We're going to do a little
more this way because we always get the podium right in our way. So let's
squeeze this way, turn around, and we'll get a picture, and then we'll go on.
You want to be in the picture too?
I'll let you go first. Okay,
everyone look at me, please.
Thank you very much.
All right.
That's kind of the fun part of the job. We get to do that kind
of stuff. And this is another thing that we actually look forward to. We've got
time set aside for the the public to make general public comment.
This time has been set aside for public— for the public to express their ideas,
concerns, and comments. Please limit your comments to
3 minutes each. I will allow the public— I will
now open the public comment period at 7:16.
As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity for community members to address the City
Council, and each speaker is allowed 3 minutes. If you wish to speak during
the public hearing portion, please complete
a comment form located in the back. They're on the table back there,
and return it to our city recorder on this side over here.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussion during public comment.
Disruptive behavior, personal attacks, or comments
about individual city employees are not permitted. If you have issues or questions regarding staff
or personnel, our administrative staff will meet you in the foyer to discuss
that, uh, for further discussion. Lastly, public comment period
is for items not associated with a scheduled public hearing. If your comments relate to
a public hearing item, please wait until the item is called. For information,
tonight's public hearing items are, uh, the programmed
2026 HUD CDBG Annual Action Plan.
Uh, there's an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, rezoning certain lands known as
scenic Mountain, and then 15B, an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City amending
the master plan known as the Master Transportation Plan,
TMP, and Impact Fee Facilities Plan. So those
are the public hearings. If there's anything else that you'd like to talk about,
uh, we have 3 minutes. Lacey Duncan Searcy.
I got to go first. Dang it, I thought surely somebody
else would I don't know if you want to go first before me. All right.
I'm DJ, more commonly known as Duncan Searcy.
I've missed you guys. It's been a little while since I've been to one
of these, so I thought I'd come harass you. No, I'm going to be pretty
nice. I want to talk a little bit about your proposed property tax increase,
the reasons for doing it, and ask some questions, and then just inform
you guys a little bit about what's going on in the life of the regular
Eagan Eagle Mountaineer. Eagle Mountaineer, okay? So,
220% is a lot. We will start there. Even if it's
just $1 a day, for some of your citizens, that's 1 to 5% of
their annual income, okay? So, that's,
that's not a small chunk of change to some of us, some of us poor
folk, okay? The other thing I want to mention is more
of your neighbors than you realize are living paycheck to paycheck
right now. Another good chunk, less hopefully,
are living credit card payment to credit card payment. Every time
you do anything to raise taxes, there's going to be
effects, especially on our pensioners. They've earned what they
have. If we're raising the property taxes on them, perhaps they
moved here 15 years ago, and that was one of the calls to move out
here to Eagle Mountain, is they saw the low property taxes. Okay,
I do not think it is the job of the citizens to
shoulder the burden of bad decisions past
and present council city planning has made and
force us to come up with those funds. We are growing rapidly.
There should be a commensurate amount of tax
increase there as well. Mayor Jarrett, when he was campaigning on
the trail, he talked a lot about the different things that are coming, and we're
going to have so much money we don't know what to do with. So maybe
let's hold off on the property tax increase, wait for some of those investments
to come, put the city hall on the back burner, some of these
other things, while your citizens are really struggling financially.
The other thing that I was going to say about all that
is I think another reason the citizens are
upset is the way it was framed. You guys are like, law enforcement, we love
law enforcement, we need to increase that. But we had to find out
in the comments that it was also for capital projects, and that wasn't defined anywhere,
at least initially. And so it's kind of a bait and switch when you say
we need to raise taxes so we have law enforcement, because who doesn't
want a good amount of law enforcement? We want to be safe, right? So I
felt like that was a little bit dishonest. 10 seconds remaining. And it rubbed people
the wrong way there. So I think a little bit more
transparency would do you well. I feel
safe here. You know, I know they want more deputies. I genuinely
don't feel threatened for my life. And if there's anybody here that
has death threats, you know, that's me. So I think when we see
so many patrol cars at a traffic stop,
you know, 2, 3, 4, from the citizen's perspective,
it doesn't look like we really need more law enforcement. Your time is
up. Thank you. All right, thank you. Thank you.
That's
it. Was there anyone else here who did not have the opportunity to make public
comment that would like to? Seeing no one, we will close
the public comment period at 7:19 and
bring it back to the council for comments to
the public. And I'm going to switch sides. We're going to go with Rich first.
Rich Wood. Great to see so many people
here, especially those here to support the Youth Council.
We appreciate their willingness to get involved at an early age to
understand how government works. I love
the way that we changed it to make it available for so many people to
participate on the council. So it was great having
them all up here. I'm a little envious, Jesse.
I hope it's awesome this year for you guys.
Appreciate the comments, DJ. Always appreciate
you coming and speaking your mind. That's the point of public comments.
I'm gonna tell you, I don't think that you're totally wrong. I think that we
could have done a better job in some of the ways that it was presented.
I look forward to being able to talk about that on Thursday and maybe
providing some clarity, 'cause I agree. I think that it's not
clear. So we're going to try to do a better job of getting that information
so that it's clear. May not agree, but the reality of it is, is we
need to be crystal clear.
Councilmember Whiting. I'm so proud
of the youth that are taking their time to be engaged and make
a difference. And we saw that with our Youth Council. We see that with our—
also with the pageants, and so awesome.
There's a lot of energy with Youth Council, and it's really— I'm really honored to
be the liaison from the City Council to be a part of your group,
and looking forward to the activity that's going to happen tomorrow, even though I'm going
to get wet and it's going to be cold. But really grateful.
I mean, Eagle Mountain City has some of the most amazing
youth, and I know it's a priority among the City Council to Create an
environment here in which they can engage and learn, and there's
a lot that's that we're dealing with to help keep them safe, help our
roads improve. And so I won't go into the
depth of all of what we need to continue to do to help this be
the most amazing place ever for for the youth.
Also, DJ, thanks for your comments, and we we appreciate you,
you know, coming and sharing. And I will say,
we could say in some ways, you know, what you
mentioned about the money coming in eventually, that is true. And Mayor Gray did make
comments that, you know, as data center money matures, it will come in.
But I was also there many times when he said the next 4 years are
probably going to be the most— the toughest years. And he also said, I'm probably
going to be a one-term mayor, even if he wants a second term,
because of the challenging decisions we're going to have to make during these current
4 years because the data center money isn't here
yet. And it's going to start maturing. It's going to start coming here.
But we, you know, looking at the different things we got going on,
we may have to make some unpopular decisions. And hopefully a
lot of people show up on Thursday night. Hopefully we hear a lot of commentary
from a lot of people because we want to hear what your thoughts are and
what you're experiencing and what— yeah, your various
thoughts and feelings. Please Please come on Thursday night. We want a big crowd,
we want a lot of comments, and we're here to listen. So hopefully
people show up and participate.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome, KJ. I just
want to congratulate you, or should I say Mayor Call? Let me start there.
That's quite an achievement. I'm really proud of you, and having had the opportunity to
work with the Youth Council last year, I'm I'm impressed
with the recruiting that you've been about. So thank
you to you and your advisors, your mother, and those other young men
and young women that have been participating there. It's fun to see the Youth Council
grow, and I will be there tomorrow if I can find my hair, okay?
I mean, I gotta find my wig so that I can come and you guys
can dunk me again. But I don't know if I'm gonna last as long as
last year. You guys beat me up bad, but I enjoyed it.
I really did. You really are the future of Eagle Mountain.
I love listening to the, to the, to Miss Eagle Mountain
and Miss Teen Eagle Mountain as they talked about at least one of the CSIs.
What do they call them? Community initiatives. Okay,
about the wildlife and nature. And for me,
that's really cool that our youth are picking up that torch and,
and moving forward with it. So anything that I can do or anything that we
can do as a council to help you all be successful and
prepare you for adulthood, I'm happy to do that. I just want
to express gratitude for our staff and for the work that they do, for the
incredible burdens that they carry. If you joined us in work session, you got just
a small taste of what they deal with on a daily basis,
and it's a— it's an inexhaustible
list of things that they have to tackle every day, and I'm really grateful for
their energy and for their effort that they put forth.
I'm grateful for the fellow council members that I sit here with. We are
called upon to make some pretty, pretty nasty decisions. I don't know how else to
say it. They're difficult, they're heavy, and I think it can
best be described as there's a loneliness to leadership.
When we ask for the opportunity to serve and to lead,
it comes with a duty, a responsibility, a burden,
and, and, and there's some honor and a blessing associated with it.
But all of those things are present in the decisions that
we make. And there's an accountability
that each of us must have. And I think
we can do better, DJ. Our communication could be better. I'm probably
the worst communicator of all, unless you sit down with me across the
table, and then I'll communicate you to death and you'll think I need a break.
You'd be like, shut up, Brett, I'm ready to move on.
But I just want to express my love and gratitude to those of you that
have showed up today. I appreciate that, and I look forward to listening to what
the citizens have to say on Thursday. Thank you.
I too am super excited to see you be our youth mayor. I've seen
you for years as I've come to Cedar Valley High School and seen
you grow into student council and all sorts of
other things, and I love that you and your colleagues are willing to serve our
community and the other kids in our community.
It's about time that Eagle Mountain has a youth council that's not embarrassingly
small, and I'm super excited for that. And I'm really grateful
for the young ladies that represent us as our city royalty.
They're some pretty incredible young ladies, and they do really neat things in our community,
so I'm grateful for them as well. This last Friday was
our 28th wedding anniversary. My husband and I have been married for 28 years.
And the day after that was my husband's birthday, and we got to go to
see Spider-Man. That was like a big deal. And it's like
the 12th Spider-Man. I don't even know. But as I
was watching the movie, there's this line in Spider-Man
that is kind of quintessential Spider-Man, and it says, with great power comes
great responsibility. And I think one of the greatest powers that
any human could be given is to tax another human being.
It's your property. You worked hard to bring it home.
You use it to take care of your family. And we don't take that
responsibility lightly.
Thank you.
I want you to know that as we prepare to make
this decision as a council, that we're thinking about you.
We're thinking about your individual circumstances, and we're trying to do
right by you and all of the residents of Eagle
Mountain. And we take that
responsibility really seriously. So thank you for being
here today, and thank you for sharing your viewpoints. And I
look forward to hearing all the ideas and insights
and concerns on Thursday so that we can make this decision
together.
Thank you.
Thanks everyone for being here today.
To the Miss Eagle Mountain, they— it looks like they left. My daughter served as
a Teen Eagle Mountain, Miss Eagle Mountain Teen.
in 2019, and they— she served 2 years
because of the pandemic. They didn't have another one, so she got to go
2 years, and it just like was never-ending thing. But it was a real,
a real blessing for her and our family.
Mayor, Mayor Call, congratulations.
That's awesome. Did you speak at our memorial service? Yes.
That was an awesome speech that you gave. I just wanted to mention that to
you again publicly. That was really impressive. And not
a surprise that you're serving as our youth mayor. So congratulations. That's awesome.
I know, I know our youth council will be led well.
DJ, thank you for being here. I think the more
heads we have, the more comments, the more ideas, the better decision that we're going
to make. It is— I'm not having any
fun. I spent most of my weekend going back through
every budget session that we are already have sat through
and copied every dollar that was presented,
gave it a name, put it in a spreadsheet. I've been through it several
times, and I just want you to know that I take this decision pretty seriously,
and I know that my fellow council members do. It wasn't long ago
that my wife and I, if I had a $10 expense, I would call her
and say, hey, do we have that in our bank account? Can I go to
lunch today, or are we packing lunches? And we have
2 Title I schools in our city that are
paycheck to paycheck. And for many people, they won't be asking
for assistance. They'll probably just cut their savings or put
it on the credit card. And so we have a serious, serious decision
to make on Thursday, and I am confident that we'll strike the right balance,
both for the residents, for the city, and for
the need. We just sat through a presentation with Ben,
our city administrator. We have over 100 projects going
on in the city, and these aren't just light fixing a curb or,
or, um, you know, putting tar in a road. These are like
major infrastructure projects
that are going on, and they're not, they're not inexpensive. We're the 9th fastest growing
city in America, in the United States.
And when you start to dig down and look at all of the projects that
are happening with 2/3 or 1/3 of the staff
of other cities of our same size, it's pretty impressive. It's a miracle
in my mind that this city is even like operating. I just applaud
our staff. They do an amazing job. And prior to January of this year,
I was totally oblivious to all the things that were happening. And now that I'm
immersed in it, it's pretty impressive. So I'm
confident we'll find the right balance.
And I appreciate the emails. I've had several that have come through.
I'm reading through them, I'm documenting them,
and we're gonna make the right decision, the best
decision that we can. So thank you.
Okay. I'll say that was 100 capital
or construction projects. There's almost 400 total projects with
initiatives and— Right, that's a lot, right? Heavy lift.
So yeah, it's, it's, uh, I'll just add
just briefly, the Youth Council came in a couple weeks
ago and I don't know if you say challenged me to the
hot wing challenge or something like that, right? It's just fun
being in the position that I get to meet with the youth as well every
now and again and some of the other organizations in the city and spend some
time. And man, we've got some really fun youth. They ask some hard questions.
Most of them I didn't know the answers to. I didn't even know who my
superhero was or whatever it's called because I don't watch Marvel or
something. But anyway, there were some hard questions. But what
did I say wrong? Because I don't know. But probably a cowboy,
Mayor. It's probably a cowboy of some sort. Ask me about bull riding. Yeah,
breeds of horses or something. I could have got that right. But, and the
queens too. I've been able to take them on carriage rides throughout
the year and different things. Just working with them is super fun.
So good times. And we appreciate all those that come
out and express their opinions and get to enjoy and
participate in the process. It's an honor for us. So thanks for everyone who's here.
And, and it's time to get to work. So the
first item we went through in our work session is the consent
agenda. Would you entertain a motion, Mayor? Yes. Mayor, I move
that the City Council approve the consent agenda. Second.
Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Clark and a second by Councilmember Wright,
and we'll start the voting with Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Wood. Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes.
Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Okay. Now our scheduled items. The first one is a
public hearing. I will note that this item
does need some action prior to our next meeting. So as
a council in our work session, we have decided to call a special meeting on
August 10th, Monday the 10th at
3:30. It'll be a virtual meeting. It was only this item.
As of right now, and we'll address this funding.
But for tonight, we will have the public hearing so that we can move forward
with some action items on Monday. With that,
do you have a presentation? No presentation?
OK. Does the council have any questions specific to
this item? I think— Yeah,
just for the public's sake, you want to just lay out
us know what it is, that kind of an idea of what's going on,
so they, uh, and then we'll open the public hearing. This is the CBDG,
CDBG funding that, uh, is allocated from the county,
from HUD, uh, and some of the ways that we could spend this money that
qualify. Yep. Um, so good evening. Thank you, Mayor and Council,
and we really appreciate you guys putting us on a special meeting next
week. Um, so this meeting is just a formality
to fulfill this second public hearing and to give folks a chance
to chime in on any city projects
that they might have comments on. So— Perfect.
Thanks. And I'll read this because it helps some— we say CDBG
all the time, and I don't know if everybody knows what that means. It's Community
Development Block Grant Program through HUD. It provides
federal funding for eligible community development activities.
As a condition of receiving the CDBG funds,
the city must annually adopt and submit annual action plan identifying
the proposed use of the allocation to hold up to 2 public hearings. So that's
this one, the second public hearing, and receive public input. Uh,
the first public hearing was held on April 7th, uh,
and this one fulfills the second requirement. Just so that we know what this is
about, because I don't know if anyone's here to speak on that, so at this
time, uh, 7:36, we'll open the public hearing, and it
sounds like there is someone. Charlotte Dukos.
Turn the mic on, please. Oh yes. There you go. It was on.
All right, Charlotte Dukos. I'm just here to talk about the Community Development
Block Grant because I was having a conversation with principal
over at Cedar Valley High School. We got some news this week that we are
opening a— I'm gonna give it the name that he— I
got permission to talk about it. Eagle Mountain Community Center focused
on families. At Cedar Valley, we are planning
to and wanting to convert one of the sections of
one of our portables into a community center. One of the
things that we would like to do as a capital project is to put in
showers. The goal over time is to have
this available to the community, not just to school parents, patrons,
but to the community at extended hours and
to have shower facilities, pantry items.
We would love to have adult ed, things like that in that space. I know
the city has been looking for a space like that on the Community Services Board.
We've talked about that, so I was really excited to hear that that was
something that he was planning on and working on at
Cedar Valley. So as we consider these funds, would love to have that project
considered for some of the capital needs in order to make
that happen. And so I just wanted to put that on public record,
and I think it would be a really great use of those funds. It would
help both our low-income and,
you know, several other groups to help provide
those services that they need. So just wanted to make that option available as
far as the funding is concerned. And, um, thank you for your time.
Mayor, would it be okay,
um, finish the public hearing? So is there anyone else?
Lacy? That was it? Okay. All right,
thank you. Uh, seeing no one else— is there anyone else that
came to speak on this item? Seeing no one, uh,
7:37, we'll close the public hearing. And, uh,
Councilman Woods has was first and they'll come here.
I just wanted to ask the question, if first of all, does that
qualify where it's attached to a school? Because I think it's a great idea,
by the way. And then can we help them to
get an application put together quickly so that that can be something to be considered?
It could possibly qualify. We'd want to get some additional information and,
you know, look at eligible activities, but I think it
is a great opportunity to really serve
a vulnerable portion of the community in Eagle Mountain City.
So I think exploring that would be great,
and we can do kind of a simplified
application to just get some program information
and then really drill down to see if it could work.
Thanks. And it would qualify as a public facility.
Okay. One, I was wondering if Charlotte had an idea of
what the target ask is dollar-wise.
Do you know? Okay. And then this is
more for the two of you. If there are construction
building tradespeople within our community, especially some
of the really If we had a big entity that are benefiting
from being able to build here and they wanted to donate
time or do an in-kind donation of some sort, is there anything
about that that would jeopardize being able to use the other funding?
It's not likely that it would jeopardize anything as long as they're
qualified contractors who would be doing the work. So that
would be a great way to leverage funding. If you had community
members who wanted to support that. And again,
we can have a larger discussion as we drill down on
any discrete activities. So in the annual action plan,
we have the buckets. We don't have the actual
discrete activities that will be funded. But this one sounds
like just a fantastic opportunity.
Yeah. OK, go ahead. Just a quick question.
And so I think you kind of answered what my question was. What I'm seeing
is in public facilities and infrastructure improvements, there's about $181,000
that is kind of in that bucket, $200,000 in affordable
housing, and then under the public services,
$36,900. And is that the
way that's broken down? Just those 3? That's what I see— I'm seeing
in there. Does that sound right? There's administration and planning Planning that also,
but it's, it's not an actual project.
And so as we consider this on Monday, as this comes back to
us for an actionable vote of some
sort, is that really what you're asking, is that we, that we kind of put
it into these 3 buckets and be OK with that, recognizing that
there's still going to be some tightening up in each of those buckets? Exactly.
And how does that happen? When, when will that happen? And How will
we be informed? Will we be a party to that? How does that happen?
As discrete activities come up with the spending, I think
those agreements would come before council for approval. Yeah.
Okay, that's all I wanted, just to understand the process of that. So that's perfect,
thank you. And if we need, just to kind of answer, I think part
of that question, if there needs to be some flexibility, there's a small amount of
flexibility to move things between buckets right now, but if
we need to move larger amounts between buckets, we can
do an amendment to the plan. So, you know, that's a possibility.
Takes a little bit of time, but it's definitely doable.
Okay, perfect. I was just gonna note for the record when Melissa asked the question
that Charlotte Duco shook her head no. So that was an
answer that wasn't audible, but, and then as far
as the And then the, uh, also just ask you ladies if you'd
get with Charlotte either after or pull into the hall and get some contact information
for either the principal or whoever it is that we need to get with to,
uh, get further information or an application. So if you guys
will handle that. Uh, is there any other comments or questions on this
one? Okay, thank you. Thank you, Council. No action
tonight on that one, so we'll, we'll come back and meet on Monday.
And we will go to the next item. It's 16A,
an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City rezoning certain lands known
as Scenic Mountain. There is— where's
Robert Hobbs? Did I lose him? I'm going to take
this one. We've done this before traditionally.
It should be pretty simple, I think. Yeah, I think so.
Let me drag this over. Just to kind of give the public a
little— You're good. Oh, there we go. I'm looking at the wrong thing.
Yeah, this has been through Planning Commission and Council a
little bit, so I think you're well aware of this. And for
the public's sake, we're going— Planning's going through the process of trying
to update the zoning map. There's a number of areas in our city that
have old zones that don't exist on books anymore. So we're trying to
go through and identify the areas that have those old zones and
then find those areas
and then update them to a current zone that matches with our current city
code.
Part of the reason why is if the public calls and they've
got these old zones, they want like, hey, how far
can I build this shed off my property line, that, you know,
it's a little harder for us to give them information if they've
got an old zone. We have to go dig back in the old books and
old versions of the code and find out what the setbacks
were and so forth. So this helps— this proposal
helps staff to be able to administer
land use application, help the public a little better. just makes
things, land use and zoning, flow a little
better in the city. So this is the property we're looking at,
200 and change parcels over in the scenic mountain area.
And so aerial photo there, and you can see the—
this is our general plan map. General plan just
sets forth our land use designations for our cities, whether it's residential,
commercial, so forth. So you can see that,
you can see the designation for that area.
And so I guess I need to be clear,
this is not only a rezone, but it's a,
not only a zone map amendment, but it's also an
amendment of our general plan 'cause we need to update Update
this map. It looks like we're we're showing some
commercial and and that that isn't accurate.
So what right now current
zoning's calling out multi-family,
calling out some old residential zones
from from an old agreement with the city. Those zones don't
exist anymore. So again, bringing this to current
zones, you can see our multifamily 1 and 2 zones
are noted there in a kind of faint yellow
and a little bit brighter yellow.
Green is open space. There's a church down in
the blue that's being addressed. So planning,
So this has been to the Planning Commission. They've recommended approval.
Staff recommends approval of this. Again, this is just a cleanup,
just to make sure that we are able to utilize the
current codes in our current version of our city code.
Okay. Are there any questions? I'll start with a question, actually,
because you mentioned the There was some commercial, but there isn't now. Is that right?
Yeah, as I'm looking, the,
the part that wasn't developed, this stuff, uh, went away.
Is it— has it been purchased already? That part
I don't— Isn't that triangle all UDOT land? It's on the north end
of Scenic Mountain. There's a big chunk of
it. is, right? This north of the townhouses?
This should be— one more time with your question, I'm sorry.
The north end of that triangle, if you go to your— back to your
proposed zoning,
the portion of that green area,
isn't most of that in the UDOT right-of-way?
It appears to be, yeah. There's 3 parcels. So Jared's
question was, is that commercial area? It appears
to be on the general plan map, yep. So that was
commercial and now is UDOT, correct? Yes. Okay, that's, that's what
I was trying to clarify. Yep, exactly. So was that your same question? No,
my question is, I mean, recognizing that you have the zoning designation
spelled out pretty clearly in the zone map.
The question I have is, what does the general plan amendment need to say?
What's it being changed from? What's it being changed to?
The general plan amendment is—
pull this back up. And,
you know, if you need to work through that, Brandon, for a minute, that's fine.
I'm just thinking in terms terms of a motion, and maybe we could do the
public hearing and then come back to that. But I'm not certain what
it is that we're, that we're considering changing it from and what it needs to
be changed to in the general plan. The zone is pretty— it's
very clear, but for me it's a little bit ambiguous about the general plan amendment
that we're considering. Aren't the
2 properties, like the single-family homes and the, and the townhomes, 2 different
zones? Yes, they they are.
So that motion's got to be two different categories.
There are two different categories, and I agree with you that
I don't feel like we really are spelling that out very.
So I think when we do a motion, and I'm just saying what it could
be, is that the the MF part or the the townhomes
would fall. fall under whatever it is concurrent with, and then the single-family would fall
under R-1 or R-2, whichever one it falls under.
2— it could be the same motion just like that. Townhomes this,
single-family that.
Yeah, then whatever parks and open space things.
Is that going to— Marcus, is that okay if they— You're going
to have 4 categories in there. So basically you've You've got the civic,
parks and open space, neighborhood residential 2, neighborhood residential
1. And you've got the roads that are all ag.
As long as it's clear in the motion, like what
is what, then that's fine. It's a little bit convoluted,
but I think we can work with it. We can kind of— so as long
as we are clear that what's public is public, what's Multifamily.
I think they can sort it out after that. Is that— Brett, the person who
asked the question has to make the motion. Well, we gotta— so
public hearing here. I'm looking right now. I'm trying to figure it out. Was there
any other questions before I go to public hearing? Is that— let's do that while
Brett's studying and see if we can get it right.
So it is 7:50
and we will open the public hearing. We'll close the public hearing.
And no one is here to speak on this item. Is there anyone here
that didn't get a chance to fill anything out that would like to speak on
this item? Seeing no one,
we'll close the public hearing at 7:50.
And then we'll come back and sing a lullaby while
we wait for the— I think Craig—
Brett, I've got one. So I move that the City
Council approve Agenda Item 16A according
to the chart of affected properties.
Yes, exactly. That's— Second.
Because the chart outlines the current zone, the proposed zone,
the current land use, and the proposed land use. It has for each one of
those. Okay, so we have a motion by Councilmember
Whitey and a second Second by Councilmember Wood, and we'll have a chance to talk
about this motion. Is that also— is that motion also
cover the need to change for the future land use map? Yeah, it does.
Yes. Right. I know that everything's in
the chart. I'm saying, does one motion cover the items
that you're saying? Well, you're saying you think we need to do them separately because
we got it. We got to change the future land use map and change the
zone. I'm asking if one motion is both.
But that chart— No, no, he's saying that the
zoning has to be a separate motion from the— A separate one. Well, I'm gonna
let— He's seen the chart twice. When we did the EMP rezones,
we did 2 separate actions. So Marcus, are you good with one motion
or do you want 2? So we noticed
it as one agenda item, right?
So, Can I make a recommendation?
So typically that would have one motion
attached to it. Yeah, I mean, the concern
I am having is that if there's going to be a
general plan amendment, that should generally come as a separate agenda item and
with a separate motion. It's in the description of the item. The description does say
proposed general plan future land use demand. Amendments and rezoning.
Yeah, typically we do that as separate items. I mean,
given that it's one item, I think it's probably okay to just move
forward with one motion approving the agenda item.
In the future, it would be better to do 2 separate agenda
items. Okay, that's why I was asking the question. So is there any—
yeah, I'm gonna— I want to make a suggestion, and I know there's a motion
on the table, Mayor, but I think that a substitute I would like to ask
you to consider a substitute motion. And the motion that I would— that
I would put forward would be to approve
the general plan amendment according to the chart
of affected properties for this item and
to approve the zoning in accordance with the proposed
rezoning map for each of the properties. That's— so moved. I'm good
with that. I'll amend my second.
You good? Stephanie?
It's recorded.
Okay. Oh boy. All right.
Any questions on where we're at? Motion's good?
Councilmember Whitey made the motion. I think that's important.
He made the motion and council members— Okay. For the record,
Councilmember Whiting made the amended motion and Councilmember Wood
continued to second. And we will start the vote with Councilmember Wood.
Yes. Councilmember Hewish. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wrobel-Wright. Are you sure you want me to weigh in? Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Okay.
Thank you. Second? Yeah, she did.
Next item. is an ordinance of Eagle Mountain City, Utah,
amending the master plan known as the Transportation Master
Plan, the TMP, and the Impact Fee Facilities Plan.
I know David Salazar has done a lot of work on this, and we'll turn
it to you. Thanks, Mayor, council members.
We're glad to be here. So the
purpose of today's item is that we are bringing the Transportation Master Plan back
in the IFP. Back for review. We're going to try and do these on a
year and a half to 2-year basis. The last
year was particularly busy. That's why we're coming back with some pretty big changes.
We didn't want to wait another year and a half, 2 years to capture.
So some of the summary will be updating some of the current transportation priorities
and plans, updated roadway names, classifications,
revised roadway cross-sections. We did update the modeling
as well. As well as the current costs
and contributions throughout, so we can get a more accurate transportation impact fee.
Excuse me. So I sent you guys an updated list,
kind of a summary of the updates we made, the major updates that's in your
packet. We're going to go through each one of them, and then I
did throw in a couple slides throughout. We can also go through some topics as
well. And focus on some key projects. So the first main update
we did was update the priority project list. In the past project
list, we had the old Mid Valley Road in there as number
one. We we were very successful, and now that's a UDOT facility, so we no
longer need that as our number one priority because we have succeeded. Now we are
still pushing that as much as we can as a city to get that moved
up in the RTP, as well as MAG funding.
So that's something we are actively working on. MAG is currently going through
the RTP prioritization process now, and we've been—
I was on the working group, Mayor and I both were. And so
we are heavily giving input on how they are prioritizing projects
because we are trying to let them know, hey, growth is a huge component for
us. It is huge, and it's been overlooked in western Utah County.
And so they— I feel like they're finally hearing us now, and they're understanding the
growth that we have and the needs and the demands that we have in our
area. So that's a huge one. The other
major change to this was we added the Silver Lake projects, were pulled up the
list, and those are the 2— that's line item number 4.
Those are connections to Saratoga Springs,
and those have been on our transportation master plan since before I was here.
But with the new high school coming online in fall of 2024,
We are pulling those up on the priority list, and so
I want to talk a little bit about those connections before we go on to
the next item. So we did a study with
Hales Engineering, and they came back with the intersection at Golden
Eagle and Silver Lake Parkway warranting a traffic signal for the movements that occurred
in that intersection. Their recommendations including removing the
roundabout and adding a traffic signal there,
moving all the crossing to. To the controlled intersection. Currently right
now, the north crossing is at Golden Medal, further to the north,
and the recommendation would be to pull everything down to the intersection with crossing
guards. And then also, they're looking at the
east leg of the intersection to realign it to a more conventional intersection.
Currently, that leg is narrow and skewed, and that can create visibility issues
when aligning with intersections, as well as limitations in site
visibility. So here's 2 photos I
have of that intersection. This is looking eastward.
The photo on the left is current conditions, and the one on the right is
AI-generated what those improvements would look like.
So the, the concerns that were brought up last week from Councilmember Wood was
we'd be pushing traffic closer to pedestrians, and it's a very valid concern. And that's
why I wanted to bring this up to you guys so you could have a
chance to understand the intentions of this project.
So the, the dimension of the edge of pavement to trail would be maintained.
We would be realigning that trail in that right-of-way.
The parking lot would stay as is, and we would take out some of the
area in between the edge of trail and the parking lot.
Also, there'd be a— with the wider pavement, we'd now go to a 36-foot wide
width, so we'd have room for a shoulder. As well,
which— and potential on-street parking, which would actually push traffic further
away from the trail. This, again, this 90-degree alignment provides
better visibility for turning movements and pedestrians.
So the other intersection was a little further north at Silver
Lake, Campbell, and Woodhaven. While this intersection was
not a full warrant based on the turning movements,
staff and the consultant did identify concerns from pedestrian crossings,
with the recommendations to improve this intersection. This would also
have a traffic signal, um, and then Silver Lake Parkway would be
realigned to tee and terminate into Woodhaven.
Woodhaven would then continue north and south, and then the southern portion
would be Woodhaven going forward.
Um, Campbell Circle, as, as Brett is well— Councilmember Wright is well
aware of, Campbell Circle would be limited
limited access with a crash gate for fire requirements, and Campbell Circuit would have to
access Silver Lake Parkway from the west a few hundred feet with their other access.
And again, this would help with the pedestrian crossings in the area.
Excuse me.
Update number 2 is Lake Mountain Corridor. So this is a screenshot from our
future classification map. It's nice seeing the 2 big blue lines on there. So we
now have 2 major UDOT facilities coming to our region.
Cedar Valley Highway, which peels off of SR 73
in the north and south direction, and that east and west is Lakemound Corridor,
which is currently called Mid-Valley Road. Now this is going to
be a UDOT facility. UDOT currently has a Mid-Valley Road in
Tooele County, and so we needed a new name. They originally
assigned us the name Crown Ridge Crest, I think it was, and not Nobody liked
that name, so council gave us some good direction on what to name it,
right? They gave some good direction, and MAG and UDOT are
both on board. That name is on the RTP right now, and it's been identified.
So that is the new name of that road. We are working on getting new
signage for Mid Valley and working with Frontier Middle School, the seminary
building, and then the fire station. I forget what UAF station is over there.
Getting those folks readdressed. Once we get the new signs ordered,
we will get them readdressed accordingly.
Update number 3 was just catching typos throughout the project. We found some inconsistencies,
some old references. This was an old document that had
been kind of updated throughout the years. Our next major update, we're going to start
from scratch. We're going to have an all-new document. We've seen other cities' TMPs,
and they're a lot shorter and a lot So we're going to go to something
a little bit different going forward, kind of start from scratch. So don't threaten
us with a good time, David. You don't want to read 200 pages?
You know, come on. It's a good document, but I told Vince
it reads like a book report, so it's, it's tough to follow sometimes.
So we want something that, you know, our residents can follow well,
development, it's easy to follow to look for the information that you need.
Update number 4, we updated the freeway and expressway criteria
in the functional classification. Before, so that first column,
we had the spacing of the traffic movement at 4 miles and it was
high speed only. With the addition of Lake Mountain Corridor,
we needed to lower that in the development regions because we
know Lake Mountain Corridor is going to go through city center and then some
residential up in the mountains as well. But the majority of that is going to
be, you know, we're prioritizing as a high-speed connector, but we still
have to cover the areas that are not. And again, our goal for
this is going to be a limited access, you know, high-functioning road, but still within
some development we will have some connections.
Update number 5 is the roadway cross-sections. Our old
cross-sections had, you know, those beautiful raised landscape medians throughout on
the major collector, minor arterial, and the major arterial.
The new sections have removed those landscaped medians
to improve U-turn flexibility, to remove the
hazards we've seen from accidents from maintenance vehicles working
in the travel lanes. It also reduces blind spots at intersections
and provides additional capacity for turning lanes. And I
spoke with our arborist. Even though we're going to be removing some of these landscape
We are going to be working on kind of beautifying our park strips and adding
more greenage because we want to maintain that Eagle Mountain feel and not turn this
into a concrete jungle. So that's a key priority
we're working on, especially along Pony Express and Ranches. Those are our 2 areas
we don't want to lose that green. I'm from the Midwest, so I like green.
So the sage is okay, but I like the green personally.
So here's an image. Of those 3
sections, the top one didn't change. We just redid it with great help from our
communications department. So we
have added a turning— center turning lane in the major collector, the minor arterial,
and the major arterial.
We've also added a new roadway classification, the principal arterial.
And this is to help with some of the confusion, because before we had 2
major arterials. One was a five-lane, one was a seven-lane. And looking at the map,
it could be confusing to understand which is what right-of-way, what's the lane configuration.
So we took away the old park strip, a parkway cross-section, which was
a four-lane road with large landscape medians and no shoulders.
This will be a seven-lane arterial, and it
has two right-of-ways: 176 for new developments,
and then the 206 is for the existing. Existing preserved right-of-way along
Pony Express and Ranches Parkway.
And it makes it again just easier when we go to the overall map.
You'll see the, the line work is just easier to follow. You know, it works
better for planning and development. So now
we're going to talk a little bit about Ranches Parkway, as this was a very
important project. It's one of our, it's one of our busiest corridors in the
whole city, as we know. So Ranches Parkway is 4 lanes with a very
large 37-foot median in the middle.
We've had major traffic congestion along the way. Speeding is
an issue. Enforcement is limited because of the limited turn—
U-turn movements throughout the corridor. There's no protected pedestrian
crossings from Pony Express to SR 73— well,
excuse me, until you hit Stonebridge just before the Maverick. We've also
had multiple crashes in this corridor. And so
with this project, we're looking to improve in 2 phases. So phase
1, we're looking to remove the landscape medians and add 1 additional
travel lane in each direction and a center turn lane. With this
project, we're also looking to add 2 traffic signals, kind of about
third points throughout the corridor, one at Half Mile and the other at Braxton,
and then limit the other access. On the parkway,
and those accesses will either be ride-in ride-outs or three-quarter. And for our residents,
a three-quarter is a ride-in ride-out or left-in because
left-outs are your longest turning movements and often are the most
hazardous and time-consuming. Where a left-in, you face traffic and you
often have momentum to make your turn in. The other accesses can
reach those traffic signals and still make their protected left-outs.
Again, we're going to beautify the park strips and add
more trees and shrubs throughout. And with this, we're going to improve
the intersection at Pony Express and Ranches. As you
know, that intersection is probably one of our worst intersections in the city. We're looking
to add dual left turn lanes heading east to north,
and then we're going to add dual right lanes south to west.
And then every leg will have a dedicated right turn lane. Turn lane as we
overall widen the intersection. So the other challenge of Pony Express and
Ranches is that when you need to slow down and make a turn, there's no
turn lane. So you now are impeding all your traffic who's already congested
anyway. So we will be having, you know, dedicated turn pockets for all those movements.
And this summer we are doing construction on the north end of that project at
73 and Ranches. We're widening that to
6 lanes, so we'll have 2 left turn lanes, 2 throughs and 2 rights.
And then we're adding a signal at Campus Drive, a high tee, so vehicles can
exit that safely. That's Phase 1.
Phase 2 is going to come 5 to 15 years later. We're not
quite sure on that timing yet, but that will come when the new sewer trunk
line is needed. From this graphic here, you can see it's under
the shoulder. I don't have a laser pointer, but it's, it's under the, the far
Right shoulder. And so for that Phase 2, we'll kick out the curb
about 10 feet to provide a shoulder for emergency vehicles being pulled
over, maintenance, or other emergencies. And then we'll install that new sewer
trunk line out there. And then there's parts of the trail that
run up against the curb, so we'll adjust those back so the curb— the
trail is not right up on the curb and there's still park strip in between,
so the pedestrians have a buffer there. And this also improves safety because
Adding a shoulder is critical for vehicles who are not paying attention
to the road, and this way they don't get ejected off the road and drive
into the park strip. So that's another safety feature we're adding.
So Phase 1, I took to MAG earlier this year for
the 2016 TIP selection, and we competed
with other cities for funding, and we made it through the concept
and the idea cycle. And we were shortlisted 4th out
of the cities for funding. This funding selection is scheduled
to be awarded next Thursday at the MPO board meeting.
It's already gone through TAC and been recommended. And so if
that's the case, this project will be a funded project through MAG in '29-'30.
Funds will be available. And so the current funds are
$11.8 million with future funds inflated.
13.8. And that is the largest project that the city will be
awarded by MAG to date.
So some of the concerns we had from the residents who live
in the ranches was, hey, can we— you know, not going to the meetings,
you know, can we maybe put our efforts and look at working on
Airport Road? Is that an option? Will that be able to kind of save the
ranches as it is or prolong it as long as we can?
And so we looked at that as we're updating our modeling. This is the latest
model of the existing level of service, and we have the
Airport Road in there with 2 lanes. Currently, Ranches Parkway is
at 29,100, which is just shy of failing
at 31,400. Before,
it was failing at 33,300. So Airport did save
us a little bit, but if we look at the future, It does
fail pretty quickly, actually. And we do know at the intersections
it's already failing. So this is a no-build situation.
We leave Airport Road at 2 lanes, Ranches at 4, just to show how bad
it could be. The worst along Ranches is at 39,900,
which is severely failing at that point.
And then the ask from the residents was if
we widen Airport Road first to 5 lanes, What does that do for the ranches?
And we just do the intersection improvements. Well, if you
look at the, uh, the image here, it actually makes it fail more because we've
now essentially relieved that bottleneck that is the southern connection and
allowed more traffic to flow onto ranches.
So if you look at what we're projecting for a build-out in 2035,
Ranches Parkway at a 7-lane would have additional capacity
from the induced demand, which you get, which is normal. But that puts us at
about 45,900. And that still leaves us with about,
with some capacity left over. A 7-lane maxes out at 50,500.
So still having capacity until we start seeing the Cedar Valley Airport come
on, which will help divert some of this traffic as we approach the 2040-ish,
2045 timeline.
So Spring Run, as we've been seeing development kind of
getting interest and traction in this area, we spent a lot of time with the
folks out there and working back and forth. Their engineers sent
through a few different transportation impact studies, and we have come up with
the, the best layout that we could for the region to service
as a third connection kind of from the city. Case there's ever issues
on 73. And so this would hopefully get us additional
connections to the Wildflower development there. Um,
it's something we're actually working with Saratoga Springs as this area develops.
It's, it's going to go from west to east, as we know,
just as the development is occurring and as they're mining out there. But that's something
we're actively looking at, and we want to stay ahead of it so we can
kind of not design things after the fact. We're trying to get ahead of
things in the city and build for the future.
So with these maps and new layouts, we went and ran new modeling just so
we could understand the better the traffic flow. This helps us understand the prioritization of
projects at the staff level and what's needed in the future
at 2035, in the near future, or at build-out or at 2050.
And then from that, that helps us update the project list as well.
Then we updated the future functional— sorry, the functional classification map.
This is that line work I was talking about that helps us kind of easier
to determine which roadway is what. And there is an addendum
I do need to add into motion if we can, if, if it gets to
that point. There was a line that was dropped off at East 1000 North.
I've got a better image of that I will show later if we can include
that. There was a line that didn't index All the way, so I will show
that in a little bit. We then went up and updated the project
cost. As we went through the project, we found that our consultant had
a lot of money kind of delineated to MAG and some developers. And while
that's great, and while we would love to have more money from them, like we
can't always count on these things because we know the MAG cycling is every two
years, and there's no guarantee of funds. And so, as a city, we have to
plan for these things and. Kind of a worst-case scenario and see how can we
fund these roads effectively. And we're always trying to look for
ways to partner and work with MAG and other entities, but at the
end of the day, we have to make sure we're capturing cost accurately so we
can have an accurate transportation impact fee.
So that's kind of the overall effects of the update, what we were going through,
trying to be consistent to get things up to date as best as
we could as a snapshot. You know, this is like trying to hit a moving
target. It's always updating every day. There's always something new going on.
But at one point we have to just say this is it. We have to
present to you our plan in its current form to hopefully get
it approved and then, you know, keep working on things in the future.
David, just for clarification for me, you said that we needed to add
East 1000 North. Yeah, so it's in the recommendation.
OK, that's what I want on the recommendation. So staff recommends City Council,
you know, adopt this with this caveat, adding this line.
There's some major development going down south kind of next to the Meta,
and this road right here, it's, it's not really a prescriptive road.
It's just used as a utility access road kind of under the power corridor.
But we would love to see that as the collector kind of connecting Pony Express
and our East Expressway. Agreed. And then, and then I have 2 more questions,
Mayor, if I may. As far as the road sections
that are contained in the TMP,
what I'm really wondering is, do we need to update those if we should we
choose to adopt this? Do we need to update those in our other section of
code? I believe we probably will want to so that they're so they
match. We have road classifications as
part of I don't know if it's sixteen or seventeen. It's in one of those
code sections. I just. I'll speak into the mic. I know nobody can hear
me. I'm getting some shakes from the back. I'm just wondering if
we need to bring back a different section of code that identifies the
road sections. We're going to need to update that if we go with this,
right? Well, so we're not changing any widths. We're just, we're just removing the
medians. So I don't know if that's going to affect code because we're not changing
the described— Yeah, but they're contained in the code section that talks about road classification.
So I just think we're going to want them to match. Okay, we'll do
that then. And then, uh, let's see, and did we contact
or have any interaction with the Wildlife Alliance? Did they get a chance to review
the conflict map? That's the last page in this TMP.
We didn't update that at all from this latest go-round. So, so it
didn't change? It didn't change. That's what I wanted to know. Thank you.
One question for me with the Lake Mountain Corridor. In our combined
meeting that we They mentioned that UDOT would
not be building the road. Do you want to just talk to
that point? It made it feel like they're going to take it over after we
build it, kind of a scenario. So I don't have a great answer
for that. I mean, because I've heard conflicting information on that, to be perfectly honest.
I've heard they are, and I've read the code myself, and that is exactly
how it's written. But I think there's other things at play. On how that's going
to go, I think this is this kind of road adoption is unique. I don't
think it's ever been written in this way before. So I suspect this is kind
of the first step to them fully taking it over. But again, I don't have
specifics on that. I know that's something we're working with our lobbyist as well,
and Stephanie and some of the other folks to
get some clarification so that that language is clear. So okay,
just a little insight. That was one of the things that I did in.
I saw like a couple weeks ago, I was talking with Mike Schultz,
and I think the key— and I was working with Stephanie on this as well—
it's more about getting it on the funding, which is a long
ways away. And once it's funded, even if we build it, then they pay for
it. It's— I think it's more whether or not it's an
internal project for them to build themselves or subcontract
it. And I think if we pre-build it,
If they fund it to a 2032, 2033 type
programming, then we'd likely move that forward
by funding it or building it with a subcontractor and then getting reimbursed just like
we do with MAG. So something of that nature is what we're working on,
or at least proposing. So I think it's a combination
of both, right? Yeah.
So any other questions? Go ahead. Great presentation.
Yeah, thank you, David. That's really helpful. It's a long document,
222 pages, so if you can shorten that up a few,
that would be helpful. Gladly. So this is just more
of a question on the flexibility
as we kind of move forward. And really, Ranches Parkway sticks
out in my mind because I was at that same meeting, and I agree,
it probably needs to be widened out 3 lanes on both sides. Is there any
flexibility in design where you have the ability
to do U-turns, you can narrow the median? I think the medians right now are—
they're built up way too high, they're way too wide, they don't get watered,
they look terrible. I don't know how many trees we have in there. We could
probably relocate or rehome a bunch of those trees, but I'm curious if
there's any flexibility in design with what we're voting on tonight
to retain some median To retain the character when
you enter our city versus turning into the city past
the Maverick and just seeing, you know, a big open asphalt field,
'cause it's a pretty straight shot. So my question to you is,
is there flexibility in the design? Are we adopting this kind of as
is? So I think, I mean, we could look at that.
Staff is recommending to get away with the medians from a few reasons.
You know, we talked about the U-turns and things like that, but there's also other
questions, concerns I didn't bring up, like water intrusion.
When you have these medians, you know, you're watering that area, the subgrade becomes soft.
Ranches and Pony have had more maintenance than a typical road section because that water
percolates through and it affects the subgrade to the adjacent roadway.
And so it eventually, it affects the crown of your road. There's other factors
as well versus kind of capping off and having a proper— crown
profile of the road, if you will. And so I think the consensus has been
just to get away from that. The maintenance has been a huge issue. There have
been accidents of workers being hit, residents being hit as well
from this. And so I feel like we've outgrown that as
a city. I know I haven't been here, my tenure hasn't been that long,
but with the volume of traffic we have, I just think it's— I wish
we could keep them, but I don't think it services the city. And that's why
we're trying to look to beautify the landscapes in other things. We have 40 to
60 feet of landscape in Ranches Parkway, and so there's a lot of things to
work with. And I'm working with our arborist to see how we can really spruce
that, kind of bang that entrance up really well as you come down.
Yeah, I mean, I, I— when you turn into UVU,
I'll use that as an example, coming off the freeway, I mean,
there's a nice median. It just makes— I think medians make it
interesting, if you know what I mean. When you're driving down a road, it breaks
up Just the monotony of just a flat asphalt surface, so that that's
just one one thing to consider. And I'm not saying that we need to have
grass; that's probably terrible to have out there. The way that we're watering the asphalt
doesn't make any sense, but some basic drip lines for trees.
I think for me as a resident, I it there's character at that
part of our city, and I just it like makes me kind of sad just
to see that completely go away. Isn't the high T— you're talking about
just a barrier at all? High T, I'm good. I'm like 80%
of the way there on that specific road. High T's, I'm good. Intersections,
all of that probably needs to happen, even the widening of the lanes. Well,
I'm saying the high T is the— there's a median, like you wouldn't be
able to go across campus in the Maverick. There is a barrier.
It's not a landscape. Right, but this— right, the high T,
it's gotta go on both ends. Completely.
I'm talking about where there's stretches of
long span of road, just having something where you're not
turning, it's just a span of road, keeping something
in there to keep the road kind of interesting.
In terms— in other words, because there's those some longer stretches where someone might
not need the middle lane to do something, can you keep some kind of decorative
feature? Some trees, shrubs, with some
rocks in there, some desert. I don't know.
Just, it's a question if we could retool that or redesign that a little bit.
Turn your mic on, Dave. Thanks, guys. Even if we're not watering it, like,
someone still has to go in and maintain that and clean that. I mean,
so there is a safety component of that, especially if we're adding more lanes and
more traffic. So I know from— if Zach were here, I know
he'd be pulling on his beard right now as well. I get it.
I totally get it. I'm here to represent
the residents that live in that area, and I
think it's worth at least considering the design and retaining
some features in the middle there. So I'm going to throw
out a quick question just to be sure before we spend time maybe doing that.
Does council agree with that? I'm not sure. that there's a— I'll probably tell you,
Mayor, that I'm, I'm not favorable to that. I mean, and look,
I, I understand the sentiment, um, Councilmember Hewish. For you,
it's about the aesthetics and the way it feels. And I know Councilmember Wood has
spoken about how that felt to him when he first came into the city.
So I think that there's, there's a real impact
there. But as, as I look at that and try to
balance the maintenance aspect of it, the safety aspect of it for
our employees who have to take care of it, the water in there and the
additional road damage. I think that the suggestion,
and this is at least what I think David was alluding to, is improving
those sidescapes is what I'm going to call them, so the edges of the road,
so that they take on that type of character. I think that's a
good compromise. But if we're
going to remove the medians, we're going to remove the medians. And every place that
they've come out, They've come out, and we've while I've
been here, we've made some improvements. And it is for me, it's too little
too late. It's like when we did the left turn pocket on Pony
Express Parkway, where you turn left onto ranches. We extended
that 100 feet, and it was worthless because by the time that it
was done, it was still backing up into the travel lane. I just think that
we have a volume of traffic that we have to get in and. Out of
the city, and that's a major thoroughfare for our city. And I know some of
the residents there said, well, tell everybody in City Center to take Airport Road.
We don't want them coming down Ranches. Well, I don't, I don't adopt that philosophy.
I think citizens in the City Center ought to have the choice of where they
want to exit the city, including Lake Mountain Corridor. So for,
for me, I just, I, I think that, I think we're holding on to something
that belongs in a smaller in a smaller road network.
So I'll— I'm going to hit somewhere in the middle on this
one. I agree with what you're saying, Brett. I think that it— that road needs
to be without any barriers in the middle of it. I think we've seen enough
accidents. Uh, it is an absolute blind spot coming out of any of
those roads. However, I don't think we
should go small when we do the landscaping on the side It— we're
well known for that entrance into the city, and it should still
present itself the same way when we do the sidescapes on the
side. It should be incredibly beautiful the way that it is right now,
in a way that can be presented on the side. So when we're looking at
that, let's, let's put our best foot forward, uh,
and make that area just as striking as it has always been,
uh, for our city. It ought to look like a golf of course, Councilmember Wood,
and, and sincerely, and it ought to have the impact of
protecting those residents from that major roadway, from some of
the noise, the lights, and some of those other impacts. I, I think that's
where we can make a difference for the residents. And can I show a quick
example? So this is Stonebridge, and so this is one great example because
we have these great, you know, trees here in the middle, then we have this
bare patch over here. And so we're looking at bringing in Trees,
you know, landscaping this up, making it look really good. So we're kind of moving
the green over, and any trees we can't relocate, we're going
to reuse as mulch. So nothing's getting thrown away, everything's going to be repurposed throughout
the city. We're going to try and relocate things, but it doesn't always work.
So— I, I think I,
I get the vision. Our track record,
when I drive through City Center and I look at our True. Or even on
Ranches Parkway now. It just, it just doesn't
look good. And I think if we're going to pull that median out,
it's got to look awesome. And I'm just going to give you that commission
to really impress, to blow us away with the landscaping.
I don't know whose job that is, but our track
record throughout the city has not been great.
As we mentioned previously, I mean, The ranches in the Pony Corridor,
it's been an interesting one because a lot of the side streets,
just like we've talked about in the city center, we've had a lot of fiber
companies come through and they wreck irrigation systems.
And I think our park staff has made a significant push
in trying to get those irrigation systems operating again.
And I feel like there's a little bit of an improvement. I think where
when we take these medians out, we just need to plan Plant some more trees
and shrubberies on the side of the road where it's feasible, because there's
still going to be some narrow pockets that won't fit trees either. So we
just need to lay it out in a way. But we're hoping that we're
getting towards the end of these fiber companies destroying stuff when they come through
multiple times every year, and it makes it
hard to maintain. And I I couldn't agree more with.
the medians, they, they need to come out. I, I think about Pioneer
Crossing and they put the medians in there and how long did that last?
And I just feel like if we just do a scale back,
we're not going to meet the mark. I think we need to like meet
the mark with it and let's attempt to do the sides and
get it up to par so that it has that look and that feel that
you're requesting. So I think I just want to
Maybe stamp this one. Let's design it.
Let's not dig holes and put trees in. Like, this needs to have an
actual design, a landscaping design, to be brought to us to,
to match what the citizens have become to expect in that area.
And then let's set that as the standard of how we're going to go down
our corridors so that it's not one area that's getting this, that this is something
we're working for over the next 5 and 10 years so that
our corridors are something that is reflective of how we feel about our city.
Yeah, I was actually going to exactly recommend that thing. Get a landscape
architect and let's do it right and design that,
and then we can see what Pony could look like as well. And we got
to put the funds into these areas. We just have to. And I think if
we can show the residents that live in that area, hey, this is what it
will become, they may say, we, we love this.
It's gonna be safer, it's gonna be better, but it's also going to look more
beautiful for them because that The trail is just going to go up right along
where their homes are. I love that idea, but I think
we got to put the money into it and actually make it real. It's the
entrance, one of the entrances to the city. It's the first impression, so we got
to make it great. 100%. We absolutely plan on doing that.
And on Pony Express, what we're looking to do is later this year or
even next fiscal year, we're looking to do a study on Pony Express to
see what that looks like, what it looks like removing the medians, The landscape
component, and something that was brought up in the last council or two councils ago
was the monuments. Ranches and
Pony Express have a lot of monuments, and that's been a big character of our
city. We don't want to get rid of that. And when we widen, they're going
to have to go where they are for the turn movements and the width.
And so part of this project and the study on Pony Express is to look
at where's the best place we can put these new monuments in so we can
maintain that feel. for the city, but still have our turning movements and our travel
lanes. Is the design what we're
talking about built into that $11.4 million? Yes. With MAG?
Yep. So it's $11.4 million. Golf course level design? Yep. Okay, David.
It's a full design. It's a lot of contingency because we know
MAG loves contingency. It's also money for construction
and management. We usually— we handle management ourselves.
throughout construction. This is a big enough project, we're going to hire out
someone to help us with construction inspection management because it's a big project.
And, you know, we'll have other things going on as well. So all those have
been budgeted. I think it's
important to mention, I know there's a lot of attention on the City Council
right now because we're looking at different funding options for us as a city.
And I think if somebody were to tune in, they'd be like, they want
to spend their money on a golf Of course, landscaping and all of those things.
And I think it's important to help people understand that one, this will be money
that we get from the state through MEG. So it's
not like we're wasting taxpayer dollars by doing something. And two,
this has a big impact on property values and different things
like that. And ultimately, we won't do it if we don't have
the funds to back it up. And I think normally we
wouldn't have to stop and say that, but I want residents to understand that we're
not just like on a spending spree, that this is a part of a long
process of finding the funding to go toward it. So that's
it. So just ask
clarifying questions again. So Phase 1 of Ranches Parkway would begin
when approximately? And then, and then Phase 1 does not include widening,
right? So, so there's nothing happening on the widening just yet on Phase 1?
Correct. So for Phase 1, the project,
if everything goes smoothly, next week, next Thursday, we, we'll be awarded this project.
Funding will be secured with the MPO meeting. Then we would then
work with, um, we have budgeted for fiscal year '27 to
kind of cash flow this project because we know the road's already going to fail.
The intersection's already failing down at the south end. And what we've done with a
lot of MAG projects is the city has cash funded parts of it and then
entered into an interlocal for reimbursement so we can get these projects done sooner
than later than waiting until 2030. And so this is something,
once next week it gets approved, I'm going to be then
drafting an interlocal with Utah County and, um, UDOT to get
this funding in place so we can begin design hopefully in the next month or
two. So, David, and just to clarify this, when we typically,
like Airport Road for instance, uh, MAG Funded that,
we built it, and we're still waiting on some reimbursement. This Phase
1, we do these improvements right away
even though the funding— is it 2029? It's, it's '29 through '30.
Yes. '30. So, so, but yeah, we start this project.
Yep, right away. And, and the great thing is, because the city uses this
approach, we actually saved money on this. We did Airport Road. I forget
the dollar on Airport Road, but when we did the roundabout removal at Eagle Mountain
Boulevard and Pony Express. That was a $3.6 million project
with, uh, it was MAG funded, and we saved, I think
it was $800,000 we left over. And they're allowing us to use that to continue
some of the widening further south because we cash funded that.
Because from this, this diagram here, you know,
the project was estimated $11.8 million current dollars,
and they budget for 2030 funds, which is, you know, $13.8 million. So So
if we can do it early, it's kudos to us. Like us,
Saratoga and Lehigh are some of the few cities that cash flow and do these
early. Most other cities, they're late. They come back asking
for extra money. So like we're ahead of the game and we're going to— that's
the way we can save our residents money and use those funds to better purpose.
So we've spent a lot of time on specifically ranches, but it's the entire TMP
that we're looking at here. I just wanted to make sure that especially Councilmember
Hewish is comfortable with— at least I heard 2 opinions
on that removal of the roundabout or medians.
Are you comfortable if we move on without? Yeah, we can move forward.
Okay. I know you wanted to go with some design elements
and I didn't want to direct staff to do that if there wasn't an appetite.
So I'm talking about the median specifically.
Isn't that part of the— No, so Councilmember Herwish was saying he wanted to leave
some of the median, and Councilmember Wright said he wanted to take them out.
So I'm saying it's 1-1 right now. I don't know. I think we're going to
take them out, but then we're going to— okay, then we're going to make a
motion at some point, like later in the meeting, that we'll hire a landscape architect
and we'll do a corridor landscape plan. That's already in
the funding. Yeah, so I don't think we need to make a motion because that's
in the budget. So when we put together that proposal for MAG, we have all
that in the estimate. We're going to want to review that plan too.
Like, where you can say, hey, look, here's what the landscaping is going to look
like. I think we'd want to see that before you move forward. And we will
absolutely bring that to you guys. Absolutely. I mean, that design will take months.
It will. It's not a quick process. And if there's opportunity
to relocate those trees— I don't— I'm not a tree hugger,
but there's a lot of trees in there. So we got to relocate
them somewhere if if that's possible, and we always try to.
It's not always feasible when they come out. If not, we reuse all the trees.
We mulch it, and we use it throughout the city, so nothing gets wasted or
thrown away. Okay, so was there any other questions on the TMP
as a whole aside from ranches? Go ahead. Yeah, I had a question. So the
last page as well, page 222. So you said that
that one was not updated. There are some roads in there. that are not reflected
in some of the other pages. So do
we need to make— do we need to worry about that? For instance, I'm looking
at one in specific, and that is it's showing a road connecting
to Canyon Wash, which we had turned to the west
to connect to Airport Road. So page 222, the last page.
So that's using a map that has— so Canyon Wash is showing a
road to connect to. Yeah. That, that was just an old background that I guess
got turned on. So if you want to make your motion, we can make sure
to delete that connection. Thank you for catching that. Yeah, there's no plans to make
that connection. That was deleted off a year ago.
Yeah,
yeah, because we cut on all the other maps, but on the wildlife one,
I guess it's still showing. So thank you for pointing that out. Okay,
if there's no other question right now, this is a public hearing. We good to
move forward? Yeah. All right, we'll go ahead and open the public hearing at 8:35.
And I think there's people to speak on this one. They listened to
a lot of discussion there, so go ahead. Quinn Lindy.
We're glad your school's still standing and not burned down. Thank you, I appreciate that.
Um, Mayor and Council, my name is Quinn Lindy. I am the principal
of the new high school that was opening in Saratoga Springs. First and foremost,
what you should know, Mayor, is, you know, I've done my fair share of
Big Mac challenges, hot wing challenges,
Chick-fil-A. I had 40 chicken nuggets in 3 minutes.
You always say no when the students asked you to do stupid
things like that. So just on the record, say no next time. You'll be better
off for it. Thank you. Thank you for it. I prepared something
more formal, and I don't know if 3 minutes is going to be enough time.
And so I'm going to keep my comments short. Most importantly,
this road that we talked about in our TMP plan to connect
Golden Eagle down through the new high school into
Saratoga Springs, this road will provide important traffic support
and additional access for high school students. As enrollment continues to
increase, having multiple routes into and out of our new high school in our community
will become increasingly important. A direct connection here will
provide our families and students with more options for reaching school and other
community destinations. It will help distribute traffic rather than concentrating
it on a limited number of existing roads. Why I say this is I have
opened a new school, I have rebuilt a school of 20— for
2,800 students at Hillcrest High School, and I've currently, when I look left my last
job building a $65 million extension onto Murray High School.
I have been in my fair share of high schools. I will
submit to the record a data analysis that I put together of the last
20 high schools that were built in the state of Utah. Westlake and Cedar
Valley are also on that list. I won't go through that entire thing
here, but I will refer you to that record and where we currently
fall in Alpine School District. With the number of access points into high school?
Quite frankly, not very good. In fact,
we are in the just above average. Schools down
in St. George, schools in Nebo School District are much, much better.
Meaning on average, we are sending about 900 students
per access point compared to our counterparts across the state.
If you don't believe me on this, go read the recent news articles about the
$225 million building they built Cypress High School,
and the first issue and the first news article that came out was parents waiting
an hour to drop their kids off at school due to the lack of access
points into the community. When communities are physically connected,
it becomes easier for people to interact, participate, and build relationships. I want to be
very— 30 seconds remaining. I want to be very clear, this is not an Eagle
Mountain High School. It will not be a Saratoga Springs High School. I live in
Eagle Mountain and I have since 2013. and I am an Eagle Mountaineer. This school
will represent both of our communities, and I want you to know that I put
my full support behind our TMP plan to build and connect our roads
because one day our marching band and our programs will march
through Silver Lake and they'll march through Evans Ranch and any other area
our district sees fit in that boundary study. I also want you
to know that I will advocate with the new school district— Your time is up.
Thank you. Eagle Mountain in our new boundary study
that will begin in September. Thank you. So any of those other documents,
if you wanna send your full comment, just email it to Lacey, to recorder@eaglemountain.gov,
and we can attach them to the record and the council can get them up
there. Can I send this to you now?
Next comment. Melissa Powers.
Good evening, Mayor Gray and members of the City Council. My name
is Melissa Powers. I live in Evans Ranch neighborhood, which butts up right against
Silver Lake, so we're all just kind of one big area. First, I wanted
to thank you guys for your time tonight and for all the work you
put into this process. I know it's been a long road for all of you,
and I appreciate the time and thought that's gone into it.
Many of you have seen me up here already, so I
wanted to talk about the Silver Lake Parkway connection. I wanted
to come one last time before tonight's vote because I wanted to make sure you
heard from those of us who support the transportation master plan and especially
the Silver Lake Parkway connection. The plan before the council
is about preparing Eagle Mountain's transportation network for future growth.
I've had Councilman. Thank you, Mr. Mayor. I've had countless conversations with the residents
through Evans Ranch and Silver Lake and the surrounding
communities since all of this started, and I can confidently tell you there
is tremendous amount of support for this plan.
To me, it's become so much more than just the Silver Lake Parkway connection.
It's about improving Woodhaven, it's about improving Golden Eagle,
and most importantly, it's about connecting our neighborhoods
to the new high school, which is really important to us residents
right there in that area. I truly believe that these
improvements will help connect our community and
give better opportunities to the students and families that are living there.
And I just wanted to know that we are behind that plan. Thank you for
your time. Ben Perez.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. I just wanted to keep my comments brief
about the same support for this master plan change.
I wanted to just share really briefly, my son attended the ALL
program at Silver Lake Elementary last year, and one thing that he was adamant about
was that he did not want us to pick him up in front of the
school. He wanted us to park right down the street and he wanted
to cross on his own and get in the car. He didn't want to
cross with all the other kids crossing across Silver Lake Parkway.
He wanted to come down around the roundabout and
get in the car. We had to park on that side. And we trusted
him at first. We were like, let's try this. And we stayed there for the
duration, but I watched countless kids go through that roundabout and nearly
get hit. Because of that? because it's a roundabout, right? There's no— there's
nothing stopping unless you're on the south side of that roundabout to let kids
cross. So seeing that there's a possibility of that traffic
light getting put in there really makes me happy just because kids' safety is
massive. Sure, it will connect to the high school and it will open
up the opportunity there for our neighborhood, but for kids to have
another possibility, 'cause I can't tell you how many of those kids after school are
walking by themselves home. Yeah. they need some kind of traffic control
to stop those cars and let them cross. So I'm already excited about what's
been happening on Golden Eagle Road with some of the lines that have been painted.
I spoke to David earlier tonight, so I see some positive changes,
but I just wanna call it out that at the end of the day,
while we all want more connections and it feels like we're all a
day late and a dollar short trying to get more ways to get through the
city, this really matters most because of the kids,
the kids that their, their parents aren't home yet and they got to walk home
alone. Um, we got to make sure they get home safely, and this just feels
like a really positive direction. So thank you.
Okay, that's all that we have turned in. Is there anyone else here that came
to speak on this item? Seeing no one,
it is 8:43, and we'll close the public hearing, bring it back to council
for Any further discussion or a motion? Can I ask
one more question on— David, sorry, I was going to ask you this earlier
and I got sidetracked. On Airport Road,
it— will that be a principal arterial street? Is that the plan?
I think my understanding was that would always be— That's correct. That'll be a
principal arterial at 176. And is that a change from the prior
plan? Nope. No, the naming has changed. It was always a
176. It was just confusing on what the name was, and so we
just wanted to rename it so it was clear what it was.
Mayor, I just— I would just want to ask the
principal of the new high school just to do me a favor and just share
that data with ASD and share it with our— I mean, our Lake Mountain School
District representative is here. I think it's really important because we press
from this side of the dais against— with the school district. But the reality of
it is, is we have little ability to impact how many connections they make into
their school sites. The state law doesn't allow us to do that. So the
fact that we're deficient really rests with our school districts and with the state legislature.
And we have— we've counseled with our state counterparts and encouraged them
to bring forward some code changes that would allow cities to
help regulate that. So anything you can do to help us there, you'll be— we'll
be fighting on the same team. So that, that, that's a plea that I'm going
to make with you. That's, that's an interesting statistic, and I look forward to seeing
it. 900 cars per connection, and perhaps we can challenge our
Lake Mountain School District representative to take that back and counsel together with,
with her counterparts and see if we can't set a standard that's better than that.
That's the first thing, and Beyond that,
I, I'm, I'm good to go when the council— and if the council's ready
to go. I want to add on to that. Uh,
Melissa is not going to hear anything different than what she's heard me say before,
but I'm going to remind all of the Lake Mountain board members,
one of the things that you all promised is better collaboration
with the city councils before you buy the land.
And I think that I want to re-highlight because it is so important
to sit down and work out these details before you've spent the
money. We had no say whatsoever in that purchase of
that high school. It was in the wrong place for every reason.
And now all of us are scrambling trying to create safe
routes for walking, safe routes for driving. That,
that's not the way to do things, and we've made that mistake over and over
and over in this this area. We need your support from a staff
member. We need— Melissa, if you want— excuse me, Mrs. Powers,
what was your first name? It's Melissa. Melissa Powers. We need our
residents to put that kind of pressure back on the school district to remind
them the importance of that collaboration so we're not putting schools in places
that it's impossible to create safe routes. It is very
difficult after the fact to try to come and mitigate things, especially especially when we
have David in here showing us that we're gonna do these large corridors
to be able to move traffic through, and then the school district comes and puts
a school there. And now we have to make a decision. Which one's more important?
Safe routes or traffic?
And I would just encourage that to be at the very forefront of those decisions
as you guys are making those, to remember we need to sit and talk before
we spend money. Thanks. Thank you.
No other comment. I think Councilmember Wright is ready to make a motion.
Okay, so quick comment to Councilmember Wood's comment.
I spoke with Julie King last Thursday, and we're actually in the process
of getting a meeting, a regular recurring meeting schedule, so I can kind of get
ahead of these things, understand where are these schools coming, what can we do as
we're working with the planning as well. Let's get ahead of this. So I'm— we're
100% on board with that.
All right, Mayor, if you'll entertain a motion.
Let me get— now I'm stuck in the wrong spot. Let me go back
a page. I left a recommendation up for you too. And also
just to remember— Go ahead. Just remember page 222,
the— yeah. Yeah, I've got that.
So my motion is this.
Okay, well then this is easy then. I move that
the Eagle Mountain City Council— excuse me.
Golly, I'm still lost. I'll do it. No, I want to do it.
Where am I? Here we go.
I'm there. Took me a minute, but I'm old and I'm slow, but I'll get
there. I, I moved that the Eagle Mountain City Council adopt an
ordinance amending the master transportation plan
known as the Transportation Master Plan, TMP, and Impact
Fees Facility Plan with staff recommendations
that are on the screen currently. Second.
OK, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember Wood.
Is there any questions on the motion? Clear.
And we'll start a vote with Councilmember Hewish.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright. Yes.
Councilmember Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Wood. Yes. Okay, that motion carries.
All right, um, we went through the legislative priority list
earlier. Uh, I think John went home, so is there any other things that you
guys need to So you're suggesting we
do not need to make a specific motion regarding the design
of the landscape architect corridor landscape
plan? Or we can require them to bring it back to us. Yeah, it's going
to come back when they build it. Okay, should we make them— should we make
a motion to require them to bring that back? Well, I think the direction's
clear that they'll bring it back, so. Okay, if they don't, Jared,
Mayor Gray, we got this recorded. Yeah, that's right. If they don't,
they did it without telling me, but it'll come back.
So we'll dang sure have that back as we design that. And that's probably at
least a couple years out, right? Because we're talking about phase— that's
phase— not phase 1, that's at least phase 2.
So then if there's
no other priorities on that, we can move
to item 18 as far as liaison and councilmember reports.
I just want to remind everyone that UTA, even though they're
not giving us our bus route, is going to be doing on-demand
for our community. And they're having an open house
tomorrow night at 3688 Campus Drive.
And UTA representatives, Utah County Commissioner
Skyler Beltran, will be there. What's cool about it
is you can order, uh, basically like an Uber or
a Lyft, but it's through UTA, and the price for it is $2.50.
And I can imagine a lot of kids who have to get
to M-TEC or from one high school to the next using this.
So please encourage people in your life that
could benefit from this to come, or just come so that you can share
information with other people, because We want this to be wildly
successful so I can say to UTA, I told you so,
and then get us more routes. So thank you.
Okay. I know there's no reports from Councilmember Wright. Did you have
the Youth Council? We saw them all tonight. Is there anything else? No. Party's tomorrow.
That's right. 2:00 tomorrow at the Cory Ride, right?
And anything there? Thank you. On what?
Liaison reports. Oh, just the Community Services Board?
Any of them. Yes. We met, had a great meeting. We're working on becoming a—
was it healthy city in Utah?
So we're excited to kind of push that across the goal line and prioritizing
some RAP tax projects. Perfect.
And we heard a lot about MAG tonight. Any reports that I'd have, I think
you guys have heard Also, I went to the UFA board meeting last
week. Everything's moving forward there just like we've talked.
So I don't have any updates as well. Mayor, can I just ask that when
you go and the vote is taken on Thursday at MAG, would you just
let us know when that's— I'm sure you will, but if you just send us
a text or something, it'd be nice to know that that passed and now that
funding will become available for us. My hopes is, as you know,
you've advocated for us too, is to move some of the other projects
up. But so far it's my— my— I wish you well. Yeah, I thought I
was going to get it done, and I'm less optimistic as I used to be,
I'll say that. But we're still pushing, man. We're leaning on them to get that
northern connection as well. So I don't know, David has to— and part of that
was what you mentioned earlier, the, um,
reprioritizing some of that funding and the contingencies. So I'll
let you know the update. You'll be the first to know. Um,
with that, I know we do have a few things to go back into In
the meantime, we have to come back out here to adjourn later,
right? So we'll, we'll entertain a motion.
Mayor, I move that the Eagle Mountain City Council
move into a closed session pursuant to Section 52-4-205
of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. Okay, we have a motion
by Councilmember Wood and a second by Councilmember Whiting. Councilmember Clark?
Yes. Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood?
Yes. Councilmember Herish? Yes. Thank you.
Are you recording yet? Yes? It is 9:41
PM. We're back into our regular session, and there's a few more things
that I'm sure everybody wants to go over. And the first one is— Motion to
adjourn. Second. Motion to adjourn by Councilmember Wood, a second by
Councilmember Wright. All in favor? Aye. Unanimous. We are adjourned
at 9:41.